Shit out of me,
dude.
Did you change the right now?
Yeah.
Yes,
I did.
Beautiful.
Fly Me to the moon.
Don't.
Don't show me.
That's all I can say this without much.
Probably they'll probably get you just
for the tone just to you.
I bet you go,
Duh,
Duh.
They own that docs,
those fucks.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is
brought to you by the fleshlight.
Someday.
We're going to have Sam Harris on the
podcast.
I had lunch with him today.
Famous neurosurgeon,
prominent atheist,
author,
genius.
Extraordinary.
And on that day the fleshlight.
I'm going to tell you what we won't be
talking about Ya.
He's responsible,
he's sensitive and rightly so.
You know,
if people found his shit online and they
went and researched that and we talked
for the first 20 minutes about the
fleshlight is credit him somewhere not
sex.
Sex Talk.
No,
but sex toy.
Maybe.
What if we disguise it?
Like we just talked about what we are
dealing with.
The flashlight was back when we only had
one podcast a week and you know,
now we do often three podcasts a week
and we still talk about the flashlight.
You know,
we'd never tried to charge them more
money ever.
I think if they skip a podcast,
they're just going to have to deal with
that shit sometimes you have to.
If it were,
what were huge.
I'm a huge supporter of the freshlime.
I,
I really wish Sam could just sit here
and we could talk about it like two
intelligent people,
you know.
Is it fucking up?
These things suck,
man.
We've got to get limp Dick.
Look at it.
It's all floppy,
floppy.
I got it.
Got It.
Yeah.
Talk right into that bitch.
Anyway.
Flashlights have solid products.
Oh yeah.
Everybody knows what it is that,
you know the commercial.
You know the deal.
I kind of am.
Brian pointed this out to me yesterday.
It's kind of freaking me out the other
day.
I really.
It is the same thing.
I am saying the same thing.
So even though I'm trying not to say the
same thing,
I'm still saying the same thing because
ultimately I have to say that to get
discount you'd go to Joe Rogan.net
and you click on the link and you enter
in the code name.
Rogan.
Yeah.
All the other things I can just record.
It will not be a bad idea.
But people like this,
for whatever reason,
they like the fact that we would like
this better.
It's better I think really talking.
I think it's just the certain parts
where you know,
like when you,
especially when you're talking about on
it and you're like,
you know,
steal the own products.
I really,
really.
I know they know that,
but just people that are listening to
this for the first time,
I know it sounds crazy to everybody else
has been on board from the beginning.
We love you.
We appreciate you very much.
But we can't do a show just for you.
We have to do a show.
Recognizing the fact that somebody might
be tuning into this.
You know what I mean?
It's like following you.
I don't like following shows.
Like I could never watch dexter mid
season.
I'm not going to do it.
You lost me because it's all it all
done.
It falls into each other and I don't
know who the fuck that guy is.
This girl.
Why is she calling him?
Well,
why?
Why am I supposed to care?
I liked the whole years.
Hold apart,
hold together.
You're already your a.
But you got to watch them in order and
you know,
someone could be tuning into this
fucking show for the first time.
I don't want them to have to know a
bunch of insights.
Shit.
You know what my favorite
thing is as people are sitting on
twitter lately is fleshlight stuffed
into their mattresses in their beds and
printouts of my face like above it,
like on the mattress.
So it looks like they're fucking it
while looking at my face.
That's Kinda hot.
Yeah Bro.
As long as they're not mean moms when
they're done,
they don't stab your picture and go
fucking crazy.
Yeah.
I wish it wasn't guys.
Maybe they shouldn't.
Girls.
So their finger and themselves to you.
I bet there are just rubbing their to
figure demons.
Vaginosis and this podcast reaches a lot
of human beings.
Hundreds and hundreds of thousands.
This got to be one girl out there as.
Oh,
Brian's on.
She just fucking get crazy.
She's probably one of those girls that
clause that or pussy you ever wants to
like a porno where a girl,
she's clawing at it.
You're like,
hey,
hey.
Are you sure your phone?
Brody,
brody Stevens.
Yeah.
I don't like when they clawed at Man,
that makes me uncomfortable.
You know,
like if I was doing that I would feel
like I was being way too rough.
Roughly screaming you like,
Hey,
what the fuck,
you know?
And this girl just took it in her own
pussy.
I'm like,
oh,
what's going on there?
Is that thing just numb,
you know,
that's what they say.
Um,
it is actually some sort of a scientific
or nothing?
No,
no,
no.
People that,
it's like genital piercings and like,
especially when they have a lot of them,
many of them,
they believe it's connected to a disease
where they don't feel,
uh,
feel things the same way.
We do,
they don't have the same amount of
sensory input from pain,
so they have to really hurt themselves.
Then there's certain people that,
you know,
there's a broad spectrum of how the
human body works and operates and
sometimes the wonky thing is that their
pain is,
it doesn't work.
It doesn't work.
Right.
And they,
they want to experience pain so they,
they'll pierce themselves,
especially if their genitals beside
sexual abuse.
That's another thing with,
with uh,
with genital piercing.
But it's also because I thought it felt
better for them.
Did you ever hear that nursing?
I've heard it with like girls clips and
stuff like that,
but I always thought they were just
crazy,
you know,
but there was the video of the guy
getting fucked to death by the horse.
Mr Hans,
that guy has balls are all peer stop.
Oh really?
Yeah,
like,
like a,
like a three ring binder.
You watch that video.
I've watched some man times.
That's to me as you've studied that,
the cinematography.
Yeah.
I could tell if you fucked with it.
If it was a brutal felony trying to cut
out scenes,
I'd be like,
no,
no.
That's not what didn't come yet.
Some shit out.
You cut some shit out the most.
Came too quick,
but ball is bulging there.
You can tell it's still full assessment
on it.
Dot Com is our other sponsor and I do
have to say I'm a.
people are getting annoyed with these
ads as well,
but some people haven't heard of before
so I have to say it in a certain amount
of order and they want to take a break
in the middle.
Yeah,
yeah.
What do you want folks?
The fuck you want me to list?
You're talking about Dr.
remember a radio host?
Just go into their spiel.
The middle of the grossest pbs.
I was assigned to this Terence Mckenna
interview and he was on pbs and every
fucking five minutes.
No bullshit.
Every five minutes.
This is our fun drive.
Our Big Fund drives here if you want to
keep conversations going,
guilt kids,
great conversation we're having right
now with Terence Mckenna.
Please donate.
You can donate by baby blue.
We can offer this and you get a cup,
you get your fresh air with the in front
of tasks,
but kind of saying he kept doing it.
It was like,
I will pay you anything to not have you
do that.
You're torturing people.
Nobody wants to hear that.
That's a ridiculous thing.
You're making people who are listening
to an hour interview,
listen to six fucking commercials.
You stop it six times.
Fuck you.
You know I heard it already.
What are you doing?
You pestering me?
You.
Who the fuck do you think you're
reaching?
Are they're the same people to random
people.
Just start tuning in halfway through
this fucking thing.
The shaking you down.
You asshole with boredom.
Cut it out.
Go makes you want to kill him.
Give me your money.
You more delusional content and the only
reason why they think they can get away
with this because we rely on public
funding because they didn't rely on
public funding and be like,
fuck you man.
I'm not buying your shit.
You're asking me to buy your shit every
six minutes.
So yeah.
Well,
I have these commercials probably after
a few times out.
You'd probably think the same.
What happened here,
what happened from the 15 minutes or 15
second spots in 30 seconds to like the
10 minute spots.
It seems like a jump.
One day.
Products you don't get ever get to the
product.
And we have to deal with controversy.
Controversy,
yeah.
This,
there's always a,
it's not just new products,
new products dealing with controversy.
Oh,
one thing I can tell because of your
voices,
the discount code,
Rogan,
there's only good the first time you use
it now it's good anytime you use it.
So anytime you use a code name,
Rogan you get 10 percent off every time.
Now that's good.
That's better.
And um,
we have a new whole new product line
we're coming out with like hemp protein
and shit like that.
And we're going to start selling
kettlebells.
Kettlebells are expensive.
They're expensive as fuck for no reason
why you can get like high quality ones
made as long as you're selling them
online.
Like we would do it.
Not trying to bring them to stores and
shit like that.
So we could sell them like same quality,
way cheaper than everybody else calls
them.
You find out a lot of things and you
start selling things like how much money
people make for shit.
One of the things about,
about,
um,
on it and Alpha brand people were like,
well,
why is it so,
you know,
why is it so expensive?
Do our profit margin compared to most
supplements is way lower than the
ingredients are very fucking expensive.
All the shit that we have in is the best
quality available.
We're really doing it like the worst way
ever to make money because we're saying
you get 100 percent money back guarantee
if you don't like if you use it,
it used to be you could buy up fucking
100 bottles and you wouldn't even have
to send them back.
We would just give you your money.
But too many people were ripping us off.
They were selling them on Ebay and shit.
So we had to stop doing that.
But.
But if you order it,
you don't like it,
you don't have to send it back.
Just tell us.
I didn't like it.
Didn't do anything for me.
Even something is strange as a vitamin,
you know what I mean?
How do you know of a vitamin is doing
something for you?
Do you really fucking know?
I mean,
how much time does it take before you're
so in tune with your body that you can
tell when you have and have not
a multivitamin sign?
If it's a radioactive vitamins,
you can tell Dan,
you can tell,
but that said,
if you take vitamins on a regular basis,
you will notice a difference in your
overall health.
I'm absolutely convinced of that.
That is my experience in my life and
I've read studies that say otherwise,
but I've also seen studies that I know
are influenced by bullshit by
pharmaceutical companies and they've
been trying to license nutraceuticals.
They were trying to make it so that
vitamins are prescription only for a
long time.
That's something pharmaceuticals
pharmaceutical companies have lobby to
try to do.
A couple of times we shot down.
The pharmaceutical companies would.
They would have the rights to sell
vitamin C.
If you wanted vitamin C,
you would have to go get a prescription
for it.
We're going to have a terrific.
You would have to go to doctors to get
vitamins,
you know,
a fucking terrible that would be,
and you would have to give you a
prescription for all of them.
He wouldn't,
you know,
I guess unless we had some open,
you would have to have things that are
approved and then those things that were
approved,
you would have an open prescription for
any extra dietary nutrients.
I mean that's.
Unless you would have it every time you
wanted to get some vitamin D because
they can make money off of it and they
could keep supplement companies.
You know,
the I the word right now,
who,
who gives it just regulating anybody.
That's the problem is that they feel
like it's,
it's not regulated enough.
You know,
and there's a good point too that there
is,
there's a very good point to that,
but it's way worse than way better
rather than overregulation,
which is what it would be if you had a
prescribed vitamins.
Yeah,
no,
get it.
People have figured out what works and
what doesn't work.
There's a lot of,
there's a lot of scientific studies
about the efficacy of all sorts of
different multivitamins,
you know,
there's,
there's things that point to the fact
that they can,
you know,
certain ones can help you in stress.
Be Twelve gives you energy.
There's,
it's not nonsense.
You know,
there's,
there's a lot of reality and vitamins.
These are,
you know,
what you're doing is you're
supplementing the essential parts of
food that are healthy for you.
It's really that simple.
You know,
and I have always been a person that as
try to,
as much as I can eat healthy and when I
can't eat healthy,
I make sure I'm always taking vitamins.
You got to give you.
Yeah,
I noticed a difference.
You got to give your body a chance.
You know,
when he was doing Jujitsu,
he was eating fucking hot dogs and shit.
No vitamins,
no nothing.
All Day.
Yeah.
And he was getting injured all the time.
I was like,
what are you eating?
What are you throwing in your body?
So it was like,
Yup,
Nachos,
whatever.
See what's around.
So for now,
uh,
if you're interested in nootropics,
here's the Spiel,
disassociated every week.
Google that shit.
Don't just buy her stuff.
Google it.
There's a bunch of different companies
out there.
I'm sure they're all,
there's a bunch of good ones.
So you don't need to buy our stuff.
If you think our stuff too expensive,
there's all you have to do.
Buy everything in bulk.
The ingredient list is all online and
it's,
it's listed exactly how much is in each,
each different supplements.
So take,
take the ingredients list,
make your own seriously.
I'm 100 percent happy if people do that.
I don't care if you buy it,
you don't like it.
You get 100 percent of your money back
for the first order.
If you keep buying it.
And then you say,
I didn't look,
there's one didn't
look this one that I have a feeling that
you just fucking crazy.
That's it.
Don't forget about higher primate.
You never talked about that.
That's awesome.
You,
you ever going to have a sale?
I feel bad because it's like I'm
sponsoring myself.
Yeah.
But that's,
that's actually,
you know,
a lot of people I think would love so
much.
Some core t shirts.
Well,
if you're ancho monkeys and weed and you
probably are right,
who isn't good to hire-primate.com.
That's my tee shirt company.
And I've actually been meaning to talk
to about this because we've got a whole
new um,
new supply in A.
Yeah.
So it's just a weird cartoon monkeys
that are getting high monkeys.
It's cool.
I always,
when I got monkeys playing chess with
aliens,
monkeys doing mushrooms,
it's,
we got new ones coming out too.
I'm gonna have to sign new.
Yeah.
I'm going to have some new designs about
monkeys and mushrooms because I want to
get some,
a stoned ape theory type illustration or
the monkeys were all gathered around a
glowing mushroom.
I just got to get another guy to draw
one up.
But how about this?
How about a bunch of those monkeys
passing liquor?
Join around at one good.
It has a thought bubble and he's like,
Oh,
this one monkey dude.
He gets a thought of whatever.
I don't know.
The stoned ape theory was.
It's like operator though,
like it starts off with like a scribble
and then it turns into a banana.
It's a good idea though,
Jude,
a monkey with a balloon in a in a joint
line and he's like,
Oh shit.
I got an idea.
Ideas the third,
they came up with powerful Ari Shaffir
or it could be a crazy idea,
so crazy at work.
So crazy that started sending up the
gun,
the fleshlight link and entering the
code name.
Rogan you get 10 percent off from now
and for every order in the flashlight
for fleshlight proper eternity.
What the times a million hits it.
Hit that shit,
bitch.
Let's start this fucking disaster off
the Joe Rogan experience.
Hey,
Joe Rogan podcast all day.
Yeah.
He said that he beat Bj Penn.
Oh my god.
Isn't that the cOolest thing ever?
Yeah.
You said that after he beat bj penn or
like,
oh shit,
we got to get a recording of that coming
fighters.
If you want to have your own joe roGan
experience opening,
just say it after you win and we'll put
you on this ticket.
They're goIng to give you some.
Give you some propers,
so silver.
Oh,
she had water pipes.com.
Santa.
The coolest boss ever.
It's bad.
tied tack one.
Yeah,
that's pretty cool.
you know what it is?
It's exactly like dyson for bongs,
like even their website,
like if you go to their website,
it's just like a dyson website.
It's so nicely crafted in India.
You don't have to like pull up the card
for it to,
you know,
take a hit.
You just push down this little thing and
it opens up the carb for you.
So it's,
it's just,
it's an awesome bong I've used many,
many times before,
but that one is just tight.
I want to get rid of really bad.
They took it to the next level.
They did.
They had to clear out that bowl.
You just,
you pull down a little,
a little stem has like a little lever on
it and then you can pop it out of the
bowl.
The bowl just wash it out and it won't
break either.
It's super delicate.
Shit.
Broke the bond in this.
Of the ice house.
Oh no.
Really knocked it over to my core.
Like a retard.
Yeah,
and bong.
Water smells wrong.
Water had peed on it.
There's no way you're cleaning that out
every day.
You got to get some of that stuff that
you can get at petco for when your cat
piss.
That's so funny.
You said that you used that.
You have ever kept the pictures in your
house?
Yeah,
we talked about a couple of weeks ago.
Piss all over mY fucking bed couch.
I just found out.
What's that?
What's that about?
Like he's trying to tell you something
like you're a punk.
You know?
I saw it.
Had a urinary infection of some kind and
that's what it was from because now
she's not doing it,
but use that as an excuse.
I think they just like pissing on you.
Yeah,
I think so.
Mad.
Yeah.
Urinary tract infection doesn't make
them pee in one specific spot.
They just bothers them.
They blame the eu when they put like a
Bird on your pillow.
That's them trying to give you a gift
card.
Your front doorstep.
They're presenting that to,
you know,
they like you.
My other theory is that my dog has been
at my house for the last couple of weeks
and so the dog,
when it's usually in town,
just like,
starts like chasing the cat and like
it's so I think because now the dog's
gone.
The cats like,
oh yeah,
I'm a P on.
Were you always liked to sit?
Oh,
I see.
Wait a minute.
Are you leaving the cat alone by itself
a lot.
No,
I mean the dogs just hanging out with
ron's dog at her house so they can play
it again.
But you ever had varans house and you're
not at your house for extended periods
of time?
No,
not more than a day or so.
I think that's what it is,
but yeah,
I've left use in a day.
I left them for weeks,
but he knows the dogs.
Not all lonelier.
Weirdly.
the only got two cats.
They like the adults or hate each other
though?
No.
Just implements and old lady cranky.
Oh,
she hates the other one though.
She's all for everyone.
Everyone hates the dog.
Hates most people would've said fucking
old cats get fucking.
Either they stay cool or they just
become a cycling.
Chicks get old.
When they get like 45,
they start hating 20 year olds.
Really normal.
It's in dogs to uphold the.
Oh man.
People get real angry.
Women get angry when you don't want to
fuck them anymore,
so we're thing,
especially if they've.
They've put like a big part of who they
are in that vested in that the big part
of their identity and people want that.
I'm hot or whatever that is.
Yeah.
When that shit goes away,
man,
it's rough.
You better kesha,
you imagine.
I would have loved to have seen.
What would that.
Do you remember what?
Who's that woman?
She was in body heat.
Kathleen turner.
Turner.
You remember what she looked like when
she was young?
She was romancing the stone.
Yes,
so I think body heat was always that.
Sharon stone.
Sharon stone,
romancing the stone.
She was one of them.
She was the fake one with Michael
Douglas.
Both the same people.
Was it for the roses came later?
No,
there was a,
there was like two.
I guess I'm thinking that romancing the
stone was like a fake Indiana jones in
my head.
It was like a comedy and I just remember
sliding down the legs and between the
heads.
I feel like there was a fake one with
um,
Sharon Stone,
like a similar.
Maybe that's body.
No,
no,
no.
I mean like a similar sort of like
romance,
sort of swashbuckler adventure type
movie.
Like really similar.
I know you only thing I remember elsie
did with sliver and it was just like,
I was like,
oh,
she was so basic instinct and it's
deliberately stepped a letdown.
Total recall that you're like,
she was barely.
I mean she was in it but not like it
wasn't like a main.
And you're like,
wait,
who's that girl?
She was so hot in the first basic
instinct,
but in the second one she was so gross.
Why?
Because she was trying to be hot and
sexy again and it was Just like a,
it was like a bomb.
They looked like a bomb that was seconds
fRom going off the shelf breaking apart.
This is the comfort level that you would
have if you fucked her.
It would be that feeling where you would
were terrified that you were going to
just stick your dick into and she just
kind of crumbling and her soul would
screech away.
She crossed her legs.
She did that same crossing the legs
thing and you're like,
fuck,
this is not right.
It was like she was trying to be sexy
and slinky and here's a completely
different kind of sexy that'll older
ladies have.
They can still pull off some sexy like
women even in their fifties can still
pull off.
The graduate lady was pretty sexy.
Yeah,
but you got to be like.
You got to slowly creep up on a dude in
like dear yourself with your affection.
You can't like spread your legs like
you're 20 anymore.
It doesn't work.
That's.
It's.
Not only does it.
I got to think about how many times have
you done that?
How many times have you done that over
the years?
Do you have creases on the sides of your
thighs from opening your legs as wide as
possible?
So many thousands of thousands of times
a year.
Is that what the fuck is going on here?
You're,
you're,
you know,
you're 50 years old and you show me your
pussy.
Hey,
slow down.
That's a jewel.
That's a gift.
Of course it does.
Of course it happens to somewhere.
Of course it happens everywhere in
boston at the chicken place and all that
crazy redneck later though.
You all through my teens.
I know.
No,
we do not.
We do not.
We're all there.
We're just coasting.
She had no idea.
She didn't know what she was showing us.
Was a harsh.
She didn't know.
She thought it was something sexy.
Shit.
Breastfed like nine children.
they were monstrous.
They were fat and they were flat at the
same time.
There were everything.
That's wrong.
A tip.
Do you remember that?
Barely.
I just want us to see them when we had
to run out the side door.
Yeah.
When?
When the second show.
We didn't even stick around.
There was so many knuckleheads in that
crowd.
Stupid fucking room.
Horrible.
I was packing up their chinese food.
As you're on stage doing jokes,
they're stuck.
Prop brown bags or stuffing them full of
leftover chinese food,
trying to deliver the stuff you've
worked on for two years.
You sure?
Fair a little bit,
donna.
Me.
I had a good time.
You wouldn't go back there and a
headline if they called,
you know,
don't ever call you again.
It's not comedy.
No,
I wouldn't go back either.
It wasn't stopped doing those rooms.
Yeah.
Well it wasn't the best room.
Dinner grow.
Go on stage.
She just stepped right up to take a
picture with me.
yay.
Alright.
oh,
that's a good picture.
I guess it was probably the same girl.
She's walked onstage the middle of my
set and wanted to take a picture.
I'm like,
get the fuck outta here.
WhaT do you.
What do you never see anybody outside of
your neighborhood before you have all
your teeth cache.
The western Massachusetts is very
tricky.
Parts of it.
A beautiful like amherst.
Umass is fucking gorgeous town,
great town.
It's a cool,
like it's a really interesting place
because it's really intelligent and you
know,
because of the college is pretty much
any college town is gonna have a higher
level of intellect or at least her
curiosity.
Cambridge great place,
amazing place.
Uh,
but that's,
you know,
the city of boston essentially.
It's just a suburb of it.
But when you're in boulder,
perfect example,
boulder,
great town,
one of the reasons why it's a great town
and so people are so smart,
they're just because of the universities
there,
you know,
it always helps having to use a
university in a town.
But God damn it doesn't make a bunch of
fucking bleeding hearts to bunch of
liberal pussies too.
That's the other problems.
Yeah,
man,
you can't have it.
Oh yeah.
Rent in town.
There's not a lot of manly intellectuals
in those towns,
you know it because it becomes like,
really,
I want to say manly in,
in,
you know,
like,
if you knew you're good too much,
liberally new,
bougie,
because at a certain point you grow up
to the point where like if you bump into
somebody like,
oh,
sorry,
I didn't do that on purpose to job.
Okay,
cool.
Sorry about that.
They're just walk away.
You don't have to fucking fight.
Yeah,
I can dummy.
No,
that's not what I mean.
What I mean is there's too many hippies
as too many people that don't have their
shit together.
There's tOo many people.
Like,
man,
I don't even need many men.
I just need this backpack.
And you know,
and people still tolerating those people
like,
dude,
okay,
yeah,
this is not perfect.
You're right.
It's not perfect,
but you can't camp here.
Camp camp in front of my house.
You gotta get the fuck outta here.
You know this,
there was,
there's too much of that there.
Yeah.
There's too much of people who only want
to look at the super liberal super
minded point of view and a really
interesting.
There was a,
I think are talked about this,
but there was that rick santorum,
guy was doing a debate,
not a debate but a
thing when we're sitting in front of a
really liberal college in New Hampshire
and he was talking and they were talking
to them about marriage and he's like,
I think marriage is between a man and
woman.
There's,
why can't it be between a man and a man?
And he goes,
okay,
what about this?
What about three men?
Is that still marriage?
No,
no,
that's different.
Well,
who's to say so why can't it be three
men?
And it's a really good point though.
Why can't it be.
shouldn't be allowed to say what a dog
is like,
yo,
okay.
Unless you clearly see the dog doesn't
want it.
But dog,
I don't think so because the dog can't
say yes I do.
How about a tree?
No man,
she's fine.
Why not?
Human beingS the consent?
Yeah,
a loving union between human beings.
Why can'T you have three?
Why can't you have four or five people
in worlds?
Embar and what's his name?
Merits.
Sandra bernhard of the other lady was
embark and tom arnold married somebody
else.
Oh really?
Together they married her.
I don't remember that at all.
That's interesting.
Yeah,
but these people didn't want to hear it.
They're like,
you know,
you're being irrelevant.
He's like,
why?
I'm saying it's a man or woman.
It's been a man or woman for thousands
of years.
You're saying iT should be a man and a
man.
And I'm saying,
why not to men what happened?
Why?
How abouT two women?
Three women get married.
can amanda mary,
three women why?
And he's right.
Why can't they knOw that they should be
whining problem?
Yeah,
I mean people should.
The social stigma and everYthing,
it should all.
It should take like that's it.
If people go,
if people look at you and go look at
this crazy ass hole with his three
wives,
like I don't even wanna hang around with
him.
That should be as punishment,
but what I don't get.
Why you shouldn't be allowed to.
Yeah,
exactly.
The only punishment should be origin.
People think it's weird.
Those people won't like you.
That's the only punishment,
but these people.
It was really fascinating the way they
were treating that,
that dilemma in the audience.
You know,
they couldn't see that.
It was just as close minded as the
people.
The guY who was anti gay marriage is
just as close minded.
They're like,
no,
you're being irrelevant.
This is a straw man.
Straw man argument to do that stuff.
They told us they're on people that are
against changing the marriage ideas,
changing gay marriage to to include it.
It's because they valued their type of
marriage and when you allow other people
to enter it,
that is not your type of marriage.
The man on one girl like cheapens the
value of what you have.
I would say that may be true,
but if that was the case,
how come nobody got mad at the bachelor
or who wants to be.
Who wants to marry a millionaire or any
of those fucking stupid shows.
I mean if anything did devalue what what
marriage is,
it's drive through marriage.
Casinos in vegas.
You didn't like that when they heard
about it.
Yeah,
but that's totally illegal.
How can we not fighting that could just
drive into a place and elvis can marry
you in vegas and holding onto that.
Just holding onto like,
it's,
it's just this way.
This is what I have in common that you
don't.
Oh man and a girl.
It's just people are assholes.
They don't care about stupid shit.
If,
why,
why would you care?
You know?
Look,
I don't give a fuck what anybody else
does.
You know,
the only reason I got married because it
makes my wife feel good.
She likes anybody gets married.
That's why women like the women like
him,
they like to be able to tell their
friends are married.
I had kids with her and I'm not going
anywhere.
I love it.
I'm super happy if it's written on paper
or not,
I'm not going anywhere.
But when you see things written on
paper,
for some people it has.
Leslie is extra significance or
culturally you're allowed to say,
no,
we're married.
You know,
like this is the level of the fact that
you're legally in tangled.
you know?
Even though it's like a ridiculous
notion to get legally entangled with a
person,
especially when there's 60 percent of
them get divorced and have to sort out
there.
Yeah.
Most of the show they have not going to
last,
but so why should you get involved?
Because you love someone so much that
that's how mine was.
I'm like,
I'm willing to do your writing forever.
Yeah,
but,
but you know,
in,
in looking at it that way,
you know what I mean?
Just in just discussing it,
it's all ridiculous on marriage is
ridiculous.
You.
What's what matters is how do you feel
about a person?
Do you love them?
You love being around him to express
that you have something really special
together.
Boom.
It doesn't have to be written down and a
button.
A bunch of other assholes get to agree
that you're legit now.
Oh,
that's fucking silliness.
And so why would gave people want it?
The only reason is for insurance
purposes,
so sick ones in the hospital,
you know,
loved ones,
but you fill it up with a boyfriend and
girlfriend or a best friend.
How about if you don't have a loved one
and um,
I'm immune.
Me or the,
I'm the urine,
my only friend in town and if I get sick
I'll say,
please contact ari shaffir.
I don't have parents are my best friend.
If you contact him,
why can't you do that?
But if you move in with a chick,
I feel like three weeks,
then you have to go to the hospital.
You're like,
ah,
fuck it.
Let her visit.
What are you trying to say?
Abortion.
Gay marriage is legal in Canada for the
board.
Really?
Local.
Don't know though.
Of course it should be illegal.
It of course it's silly,
but of course why that when it devalues
their marriage,
I feel like the same as when a black
person lives on your block and it
devalues a property of her home.
And that's exactly what you're sort of
doing.
I don't want them here.
Would,
if you know neil tyson moved in on your
neighborhood,
do you really think that would devalue
it?
Tyson,
that the really famous astrophysicist.
Oh,
black guy,
brilliant.
Super genius dude.
He never seen him rate youtube property.
Perhaps.
How could it,
he's a super,
super racist,
wouldn't know.
They drive by and go,
oh,
and he has kids and they assume as kids
will steal.
Sure.
Imagine that like,
fuck,
how long is that going to be fighting as
is that going to be a little bit in my
block.
It was a nice black family and then
their kids inherited it after awhile and
they had their.
They were a little,
I don't know wherever they were from,
but like there are more party people and
they had a car parked in,
there were bullet holes in it,
so my mom just start referring to them
as the murderers,
murderers,
homes.
They had a car with full of holes in it.
God damn it.
I didn't see that though.
Holy shit.
Wow.
Who shot at them?
Did you ever ask him?
No.
Murderers,
murderers.
I mean,
I didn't think there were murderers but
not speak casually.
Refer to them as how you are trained
now.
That was in your little head.
It is fascinating how much,
how few white people can relate to like
really poor black people and crime
ridden neighborhoods.
Oh,
you know,
like district nine than it is like your
life.
Yeah.
Dude.
Really bad neIghborhoods like you.
You've seen what especially like in
africa know you've seen the
documentaries ever seen,
uh,
the vice piece on Liberia into their.
Do you want to think it's the end of the
world watched the vice piece in Liberia
where they're eating irregular
cannibalism,
warm old,
regular cannibalism in this guy,
one of the,
the war they talk about it's children.
They would kill children.
They would go over there and kIll the
children,
sacrifice them,
eat their heart.
They were alive,
drink their blood,
do all because it made them.
TheY believe that it made them
vulnerable and battle.
Charles taylor,
who's a crazy dictator,
but nobody knows him just because his
name is too normal.
Really wasn't it?
he was the dictator in Liberia.
There's took power and Charles Taylor
was vicious.
What a brilliant move.
Just have a really normal way worse than
gaddafi or any of these people we
thought were bad.
Really horrible story.
He let all that stuff.
What was his name again?
Charles?
What?
Charles taylor.
Wow.
Maybe not better,
but I think that's the guy who makes
converse all stars.
Chuck taylor.
It wasn't dave librarian.
Charles taylor.
We got it.
You nailed it.
paranoid that I got it wrong.
It was the 22nd president of Liberia
from 1997 till his resignation in 2000
friends and colleagues had to flee.
Really?
Yeah.
Whoa.
Scary fucking place.
She's crisis africa.
Scary.
there's so many spots are so god damn
scary.
do what they want.
Why did your people take down tower
seven heart?
Well talked about it.
After awhile I realized you know what?
Everything down.
I thought it was an insurance thing and
ensure thing.
It's like if it's old fucking knock it
down.
We can't do anything with it goes top to
gone.
Just knock it down.
He just decided to be better.
If it was attended by random like islam,
could you imagine if you actually did
have buildings already set up?
If every building was set up with
explosive,
so at any point they could just look at
it so you don't have to write rig it
like that was like a thing.
Well,
when you want to get your building
demolished,
here's a good thing.
You just press this button and the
ability goes away.
You just have to,
you know,
hire some monkeys to fucking pick up the
happiness that you manage them.
That's how they did every building they
couldn't because everybody would be
like,
people will be just trying to get there.
Another plane that was supposed to go
that waY.
Supposedly.
When was that going to happen?
There was a bunch of plans.
One of them that got shot down that was
supposedly they don't know where that
was headed.
There might've been headed for the white
house.
Yeah,
that's what they said was headed south.
That was 93.
That was the one that they said that the
people brought it down,
but the same.
Um.
Yeah.
But um,
uh,
yeah,
rumsfeld actually made a mistake in an
interview and said he got shot down.
Really?
Yeah.
He said,
uh,
you know,
in 93 they shot down a 93 flight.
90 three.
He like said it before.
There's a lot of people that are
positive that it was shot down because
of how far the debris was.
The debris went as far as like seven
miles and then they made that let's roll
thing.
I've heard that before and my thought on
that was like,
that'd be okay if they shut that down
clearly by the other three,
like it's going to be.
It's going to find is something down.
It's tough choice,
but you got to do that.
There were eye witnesses,
this other fighter jets who knows.
Either way it's horrific.
If they crashed,
it's horrific.
If it got shot down,
but it's somehow or another people want
to know about that.
The mystery,
the mystery of what happened.
Do you think they were starting to
hijack somewhere in the middle of mid
conversation going and you know,
they checked my bag,
they checked the whole fucking bag was
pre nine slash 11 was still too much
security for a lot of people.
Some people were probably upset,
but my.
My take on it is when bush got on,
when they,
when they told the whole story,
the whole let's roll story,
you know that the guy said,
let's roll.
As they got out and they were going to
go fight the terrorists and they brought
the plane down.
My bullshit alarm on my bullshit alarm
was going off.
I was like,
this is a story I have no idea,
but it does sound like a great story.
This is like Jessica Lynch member.
They had that story where they said that
they had rescued her and hail of gunfire
because she was being in prison by the
iraqis and they saved her.
This brave pretty girl.
When it turns out she was actually in a
hospital.
There was no gunfire at all.
Yeah,
it's horseshit shit made about horseshit
story and she came out public with it
and people gave her death threats
because she'll against the story.
Yeah.
Oh dude.
She got a lot of death threats.
The story,
her story was quite simple.
She got she.
There was some sort of a firefight or
some sort of a military incident where
she was injured.
She was brought into a hospital.
They came and got her from the hospital
and they brought her back home.
Okay.
That's her story.
That's what really happened with the
United States.
Said was that they had to go and rescue
her and they went in guns blazing to go
get one of our own dot,
dot,
dot.
And that didn't happen.
Did not happen.
What did happen?
Just that.
Just they went and got her at the
hospital.
Oh,
they went on.
They got the ones in the hospital,
got her,
brought her home and then they choose a
local hospital.
She was in a hospital in Iraq and they
concocted a crazy story pretending that
she was,
you know,
that they had rescued her,
but all day they got their tissues.
And then another example is that the a
football player,
what the fuck's his name?
Human resources is really gay and he
says like,
I'm a guy that went in there and they
just destroyed everything was,
you know,
like he just writes these press releases
that are just is guy.
I'm sure it's one person.
One group actually gets to decide what
the story would be,
but the point of it is there's,
there's a fire,
right,
but they made him a hero for me here.
At first.
I think it's normal for them.
It's standard operational procedure for
them to lie,
so anytime they get a situation to
bullshit and spin the truth,
it seems to be the precedent.
It seems to be what they do.
You know,
when you.
Whenever there's some sort of a
situation and then they tell you a
story,
you can't prove that the let's roll is
not real Bible.
I didn't have to go down.
That's why I was wondering why that If
they took over the claim to the bitter
end and like american,
the font,
just somebody dove powell and pow and I
don't know man.
I don't,
you know,
I,
I don't want to believe that,
you know,
I don't want to believe that they would
lie that much,
but I do believe that they could though,
if they thought it was coming to the
white house,
they would shoot.
You should.
I think you probably should.
Going to get there.
It's going to kill the people anyway,
so you're making a decision to calibra
failed.
If people can't take control of the jet,
if it does shut three attacks,
right?
Or to go talk to this play,
they have no communication with it.
It's going out of.
It's out of where it's supposed to fly.
Yeah.
So if you could pull up the audio,
pull up the audio of donald rumsfeld.
Flight 93.
shot down.
Just pull up that donald rumsfeld,
flight 93.
Shut down.
I think it's on youtube.
He could of course.
He could have also been a slip.
He could've just.
I fuck up all the time.
I'll say,
I'll say to you,
brian,
why'd you do that?
he called brian.
I'd be like,
no,
I didn't because you don't even realize
you did in the military too,
right?
What's that?
He served in the military at some point.
Rumsfeld?
No,
never really hawks.
no.
That's the thing about all of them.
If the people who bombed the mess hall
and the people that get the bonding in
Spain or the people who attacked the
United States in New York shot down the
plane over Pennsylvania,
pentagon
shot down because he's different.
He's referring to the people who did the
bad things.
Yeah.
That sounds like he was saying brought
down the plane.
Shot down.
Yeah.
Like they brought it down.
They died,
but he was talking about the bad people.
They wouldn't be the ones who would have
shot.
That's a bad video.
Okay.
So now we know.
He didn't really say that
I smoked mouth poop today by accident.
There is a huge mark about this big
that's been outside of my back patio for
the last couple of days and it hasn't
moved like a word at all.
So I've been looking at everyday.
I mean as an been,
hasn't moved at all what I was trying to
say that,
but as it moved forward at all,
but it was really cool because it's like
there's like a little passe cheetah for
look like cheetah for on it.
Like it would be a chia pet cheetah
cheetah.
That was like,
well,
oh I see like the pattern with cheetah
and then there was like these weird
parts that looked like almost like
feathers have like an hour.
It was just really weird,
like looking at it everyday and then
today I shut the door really hard and it
fell down and it just start vibrating
for about 10 minutes.
Like it wasn't dead.
It was just vibrating.
So I'm just sitting there at it and then
it shoots out like this orange
fluorescent orange thing.
I think it was shit,
but it was like fluorescent orange.
It looked really weird,
like it didn't look real and then it
flew away out of nowhere.
So I'm sitting there like,
what the fuck is that orange stuff?
is it shit?
I just flew away.
Yeah.
So it fell to the ground,
had an epileptic seizure for like shit
all over itself and then flew away.
It's just shit out like a,
like a super,
super small little bubble of like
fluorescent orange shit.
And so I'm sitting there like playing
with it with a match,
a stick.
I'm just looking at the orange and I put
on the end of my cigarette and smoked
it.
I don't know why I did it.
Just to see what would happen.
You got a real problem about it.
It was weird looking with orange.
C,
people were Thinking there's a show in
march.
Third you fuck with people keep saying
mark.
Third,
the new york's fucked up on the day.
Third may,
ladies and gentlemen,
the people asking about,
um,
what's the.
There is a March 3rd show in new embraer
California.
But uh,
we had it listed as march,
third and fourth or whatever the fuck it
was in New York city.
And it's not New York city's may.
So I apologize for that.
What's the vendor you don't?
Um,
I don't know.
Some theater.
What does brian do you know the now I
know.
Well,
we're doing.
There's a ufc on fox.
I'm in New Jersey has referred the mat.
So we're at the manhattan center and
then at the tabernacle in atlanta on
4:20.
Oh shit.
Crazy.
I'm trying to do my special.
They're just trying to organize it if as
quickly as possible.
August,
it's a little more,
I feel like I have to.
I feel like I have to know why not.
You should do That and be there.
Right.
Doug benson does every year.
What types of special?
Every year on the cd on four slash 20,
which is a.
He's no one is more like marijuana
connected.
IT's inexorable.
You can't pull the marijuana from day.
You can't recognize.
Where does doug and the marijuana begin?
Where does the marijuana begin and you
know doug,
you know what I mean?
This last time,
that last ice house,
he seriously,
from the beginning to the end,
did not stop packing bowl,
smoke,
packing,
cold smoke.
Whenever people ask density.
Good.
I was like,
what?
You just give them another pipeline,
which is what's really crazy is there's
like a conspiracy that he doesn't really
smoke weed because I guess he got on
some show somewhere and gave like a
halfhearted bong hit and nyla.
He's not far from the truth.
Fake stoner,
donald sutherland and invasion of the
bodY snatchers.
When he found a woman at the end,
he pointed her out.
I remember that.
I don't,
I don't think I saw that one.
Well,
it's like everybody had become one of
the aliens,
the been taken over by the body
snatchers,
but a few people stayed awake and we're
surviving by,
you know,
by figuring out how to stay awake.
And uh,
this woman came up to donald sutherland,
[inaudible] she's,
you know,
they were in the resistance together and
she was like,
hey,
I finally
got free.
I'm,
everything's fine.
And he looked at anybody because he had
been taken over and if he saw that the
body's natural zombie movie or no,
it's an alien alien.
These pod students dope.
One of the body snatchers with donald
sutherland is all fucking great movie.
They did it with.
Not meg.
Meg tilly.
Yeah,
tilly.
jennifer tilly.
I think it was meg tilly.
Meg tilly was the real kind of innocent
one in jennifer tilly who was kind of
like,
the dirtier one gets dirty thing was
meg.
Yeah.
She's apparently sirius pro,
right?
Yeah.
We met her in open nantha.
Yeah,
she was cool.
Um,
uh,
but meg tilly was her sister and her
sister was the star of the.
There was a more modern version of
invasion of the body snatchers.
Still pretty fucking good.
But god,
I remember getting like a little action
movie.
He,
you know,
wasn't like as good as the first one
that donald sutherland.
One is shit that's back when donald
sutherland was just a fucking killer
actor to me.
Still is.
He's still in the house.
Yeah.
Donald sutherland was fucking awesome
man.
That evades the bystanders.
I forgot about that.
I'm going to see that this week.
That's a good one man.
And whenever this on netflix,
I saw.
What did I go see the other night?
I saw that.
Uh oh.
I saw the wolf movie.
Which one?
American wearing gray gray.
It was,
it was fun.
It was fun,
but it made it out like wolves or just
jacking people left and right up there
like he was hired to shoot wolves and
the wolves were like,
we're running at people full clip and he
would take them out like it was a
sniper.
Like that's one of the opening,
which never happens.
Man.
Wolves don't just run on people so often
that you need a guy with a rifle who's a
sniper picking the wolves off or that's
not real,
you know,
so these,
it was weird because like he saves a
guy.
Wolf's were like,
there were like monsters in this movie.
There weren't like wolves.
They were like,
he took wolves and gave them some.
It was like some unnatural pack of
wolves.
They behaved completely unnatural.
So it was like it was,
it was,
it was part of it.
It was hard to swallow.
I would've liked it if they were
diseased or turned out.
They had got some fucking crazy
radiation or experiments.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
But instead they try to play it off.
Like these wolves are killing people.
Wolves have only killed 100 people ever
in the history of humanity.
Really?
Yeah.
There's like a website where there's a
wikipedia,
but there's also another website that
like documents,
wolf,
human deaths,
and a big majority of them,
I believe are in Russia.
I think in Russia it's more common.
They got meaner people up there and
meaner wolves,
more bad ass thing of,
well,
if a 10th and a guy had been killed and
he was half of the yellow,
this is far greater than you ever could
have imagined.
Yeah.
Well it's super rare.
There are a woman died like I think in
2005 or something like that.
We'll put that in,
in,
in Alaska,
but she was running and I think I think
if you
fuck up and you just run by a wolf in
the wrong time,
they can't help but chase you like a dog
just like a cat with a ball of yarn and
they'd say that's a big part of a
mountain lion attacks is people are
jogging or people riding bikes and they
just can't help it.
The mountain lion thinks they're running
away,
which is the next operating system from
by the way.
They announced out in mind,
which is so weird.
It seems like they're getting to the
bottom of the barrel of cats with apple
and the whole cap thing and it's just
like,
you know,
android with her other little names that
they're.
They're just.
They shouldn't even have to see which.
Which product or an animal gets think
first or name it after something.
Smartest.
Fuck.
We'll catch a big on the internet.
Chimpanzee.
Why can't that be,
you know,
mac chimpanzee,
cat.
Maybe that'll be a 20 from then on.
You know what they'll do?
They'll just.
Genetic engine.
My cats are pretty to look at it.
I don't want to see monkeys.
Love chip and I turn on my coherency.
A big ape.
I don't really.
I don't want to see a.
How dare you.
It's like looking at a guy naked.
I'd rather see a cat.
Really?
Yeah.
Dude.
I love looking at chimps.
You don't like looking at champs.
You're.
You're so weird though.
Do you think that that was part of the
animal side of?
No,
I mean like if I see if I,
I,
if I go to the zoo,
I love looking at monkeys and apes.
but your computer,
you don't like it.
If I see it every day,
I don't want to look at monkeys
everyday.
That's what a cat's.
Okay.
Yeah,
I guess he can't look at it.
I go look at tiger's almost everyday
because to me they're like avatar.
That's what I'm saying.
tiger really is like an avatar creature.
Have tigers didn't exist and it was in
the movie avatar.
So gigantic,
gigantic colors are spectacular,
you know,
the whites and the black stripes in the
yellow and orange,
like tigers are amazing looking like why
would nature ever want you to be so
beautiful?
And that's fucking other animals ways
of.
I'm watching out for the tiger.
Protecting myself.
Yep.
Got handicapped a little bit.
Yeah.
Maybe he made theSe,
this guy is so bad ass.
We got to make them really bright.
It should Be bright.
Then if it was the same thing,
gorillas don't kill people very rarely.
they killed people.
People fuck up and you know,
jog over a nest or something like that.
but for the most part,
gorilla was vegetarians.
Yeah.
They eat bamboo and shit.
They don't even eat monkeys.
What do you think about this Virginia
stuff with abortion?
Fucking crazy illegal.
Pretty much the trying tO.
Well,
have you heard the,
um,
the thing about ultrasounds?
Yeah.
They're saying that you have to get an
ultrasound before you have any sort of
procedures because they want you to look
at It.
Yeah.
I want you to recognize tHat that's a
life form somebody,
somebody,
somebody said that,
um,
one of the democrats said something
like,
uh,
this is the first time that we've ever
dictated like a medical procedure.
We've cOmmanding a medical procedure.
I'm definitely the weird liNe to cross.
It's a total weiRd line to cross because
you're a,
you know,
you're,
you're making the decision for the
person,
you know,
you're,
you're deciding,
hey,
you have to do that.
You know,
they could get an ultrasound if they
want to.
They know they can sit where you're
making them.
You're making them look at it.
That doesn't make sense to me.
That doesn't.
I don't see why you one more time before
you do it.
Yeah.
Why do you,
we know what's going on here.
The real issue is what's going on here?
What's going on here as you're killing a
baby?
One guy said it.
It goes.
The only reasons it's legal.
One of the republicans only reasons
legal because,
because,
uh,
it's for convenience and I was like,
that's true.
that's what we decided as a society.
Yeah.
We'll let that go.
It's a weird line right though,
because at a certain age you can't do it
anymore when somebody is months old.
Weird.
Too crazy.
But that's what we do all the time.
That's when we raise the speed limit.
Fifty miLes an hour when you know,
this is going to mean more deaths.
This year dude,
I had a friend back in New York who,
uh,
his girl got a late term abortion really
late,
like really late,
like it was illegal and it was,
have the number,
I don't.
It was a,
it was reallY crazy because she was
showing really?
Yeah,
she was showing and uh,
and she had an aBortion.
It's fucking dark man.
It Was dark and they wound on,
went on to have children together,
which is even good as they went on to
have children together.
But at the time I was really freaked out
by.
It really freaked out because I don't
remember how many months it was in,
but it was enough where,
you know,
they told me,
I was like,
oh shit.
Like this is dark man.
You know,
it's,
I think that should be allowed to do.
You should be allowed what to do.
What do you mean later abortions?
You should be allowed to do them.
No,
no,
like get them.
Oh,
you should be able to get them to the
same thing.
There's no reason for that.
Like clearly at some point it's like
this light is going to continue.
I think Whatever it is right now,
it's fine.
I think that's enough time for you to
find out that you're pregnant and you
need to do either make the decision,
yes or no,
but I think anything after that,
after what?
Like,
like late term abortions.
WhaT month is that?
Um,
I think three is that what it is,
is the longest you can go.
So you know,
I think with late term is six and on.
No,
I'm saying what it is now.
It's six months,
six months.
Jesus christ.
That's a baby.
People still want to do it at four.
That's crazy.
That's just to me,
that's crazy.
That's human life.
It's very clearly human life.
One difference between.
But let me,
let me get.
Let me be real with you here.
Part of part of what you're saying,
you're kind of being objective about it
and you're being honest about it,
but part of what you're saying is a
little bit for shock value,
but no,
four months while you can't even see a
bulge at that point.
Oh yes,
you can.
Yes.
For months never been in a science
museum,
so,
but three months you can't,
but for months you can.
You can as well look this up.
I think three months again as well,
so then you can see it,
but it's still okay to do it that way.
OkaY.
Let's look at fetus.
I think it's remarkably soon that you
could tell it's person.
You've seen a baby's butt hole before
you just brand.
So when would you think it should be
illegal?
As soon as you can see any sort of
bulge.
Yeah,
look at this three months,
dude,
but that's what you're saying.
That's when you think it should be gone.
This is three weeks.
This is.
I mean,
this is 13 weeks.
This stuff.
That's a baby man.
It's a fucking baby sucking its stomach.
Three months.
Can you see it through the stomach?
Can you see a bulge in the woman's
stomach?
Now I want to just show me a picture of.
I don't know how much blown that up
maybe.
I think for different.
some women.
Yeah.
So,
okay.
You're saying that's too far.
That's too far.
And it's like how far that sound by the
way.
That's image.
This is a real image.
This is an image of what it's
represented.
This is what it looks like.
Yeah,
it's a human life,
but it's like almost immediately,
um,
you're saying with our,
with our current microscopic,
uh,
like abilities.
As soon as you can make it out based on
that,
that's how it should be illegal.
That's where it's life.
Well,
it's interesting.
That's the,
that's a really good question.
So random.
It is a really good question,
but at what Point in time does it become
a life?
Does it become a life when it's two
sales?
No,
is it 20 cells and I think as soon as
they start moving on its own,
so it was it going to leak.
It can start leading to life and it's
like life,
but it's life inside you,
man.
When you,
when you have children,
when your wife is pregnant or if you
ever have a girl that's pregnant,
you touch your stomach.
When you know the baby's only a few
months old,
they start kicking man.
So it's when you can feel it through the
stomach skin.
I mean that's some living thing inside
of her.
I don't know where you can feel it like
the week before you can feel it.
That's not a living thing.
Um,
no,
it's still living is not quite strong
enough to get through the skin layer.
It's moving.
I'm saying it's,
it's a,
it's a living thing,
mean living way before that,
but it can't.
It can't.
Like you don't know that it's moving
around until you start suits,
when you can feel that's what you think
is true.
When I was just saying hand,
you should feel totally on its moving
long before this late term abortion
shit.
It's moving,
you know,
I don't know when you should be able to
draw a line,
but it is a.
It's a philosophical in a moral
question,
right?
It's like what time does it become a
life and no one is really wrapped their
head around that,
but for a lot of liberal people,
they don't even want to address the
argument.
IT becomes more of of you trying to take
away a woman's right to choose.
We'll look at their names and the tooth,
but the tooth,
but not even against each other.
One is pro life.
The others not anti-life.
Right.
And one is pro choice.
The other one's not against people
having choices.
Yeah,
but it's the choice to kill you.
That's my choice.
Yeah.
But that one prolife once a month and I
haven't talked about the same things
sort of they are though with what's
really crazy is the most pro life people
are also pro war.
It's one of the funniest things ever,
man.
This is the weirdest thing ever.
How many.
I mean the numbers are staggering.
How manY people are concerned about the
babies and how many people are out there
and they're the same people that support
the war and the same people that would
be happy to,
you know,
to support the troops.
Did you ever more troops?
You ever have a um,
drive by one of those,
a bunch of groups of fucking weirdos get
on the corner with flags and big signs,
honk,
confused,
support our troops.
Like,
how is this helping anybody at all?
How has this,
how is this boosting morale for people
who aren't really there is it,
is it for the random soldier to that may
be getting shipped off and gets to see
this before they leave?
What is this for?
Is some
kind of rah rah,
rah.
Dedicated.
What do you,
what do you think this is?
Yeah,
but people do get mad at you if you
don't honk.
I've seen there was,
um,
on the corner about three or four miles
away from here.
There was this one intersection that was
like a hot intersection for some reason
for gaY marriage folks.
People that were anti gay marriage and
people that were into the war for same
corner and the one member of that
proposition eight shit,
when that was going down,
they were all just lined up.
You know,
marriage is between a man and a woman
and god is not in the fucking quoting
psalms and shed and holding it up.
Punk if you believed marriages for a man
and woman and the other time was this
war thing.
People were fucking screaming at them.
You know,
people screaming at each other know,
get the fuck out of America.
There was several times where I drove by
where people in cars,
we're screaming at the people on the
street and they were screaming
back and forth at each other was just
arrest him because it's against the law
for you to honk your horn,
so telling people to honk your horn,
be against the law to honk your horn.
It is.
Why do you have a horn?
It's only no way you can get a ticket
for a honking horn for no reason really,
for no reason to go.
Maybe you saw some shit right there.
I thought I saw some shit.
What's the reason you see that guy?
The guy that was coming?
No,
the other lane that was coming towards
me.
There's someone who's headlight.
Yeah,
but still it's telling you to do
something illegal and people holding
signs up for that.
Really illegal.
I feel like that's one of those myths
and I feel like you should be able to
like drive through an intersection and
honk and your friends.
Can you do that?
I think it's one of those things where
it's like it's illegal,
but no one's ever going ticket for it
unless you've started just honking your
horn for no reason.
If you saw someone in the corner and
there was a cop there and you are brett
brown,
what's up?
You know?
Do you think,
have you been arrested for that?
Is that what you would say?
Get arrested but get ticket.
You get fined probably or a warning.
Most likely we got too many rules.
There's way too many.
If that really is a law that's.
That's pathetic.
I mean,
you shouldn't be a con.
You shouldn't be blaring.
You're fucking hormone everywhere,
but there shouldn't be a law against it.
Here's a really interesting video
online.
Um,
it was taken in Nevada where some dude
went through a sobriety checkpoint and
wouldn't answer any of the questions.
I remember that.
Did you see it go,
I know my rights to roll down your
window to place it goes.
Is that a direct command or not?
I think I was like,
please hold on your window is like,
no,
I will not.
It just kept standing there like,
oh bang,
that is
you're.
There's actually a few of those videos
online.
But uh,
that is what,
you know,
when,
when a cop says,
you know,
I want to check your car.
Yeah.
You don't have to say yes or say no.
No,
no.
They don't.
They say an asking matter.
Ma'am,
could you please open the car door?
You have to say,
all right,
we're going to check your car.
Okay.
Not okay.
In the end is really imPortant because
you go,
oh,
no,
you're not going to check my car.
Alright,
we're gonna.
Bring the dogs.
Go get your dog.
That's procedures that we need to do
some weird dude check in my trunk.
Yeah.
They have to ask in a way that's asking
that Donald Trump,
they can't say that.
The problem is they'll just get the dog
and then they have a dog.
They make the dog bark and go,
yep.
Alright,
we're checking your car.
Now if the.
Well,
how many do you think cops actually
plant evidence?
Do you think that's not.
I don't think they plant evidence.
The majority.
I'm sure they have plants in it.
Evidence,
but cops planting evidence.
Humongous majority.
Never planted any evidence.
I mean everyone says the cop is planting
evidence,
but you know that fucking guys just
like,
why would I do that?
Now you remember that movie cocaine
cowboys.
do you remember that movie?
That
was the movie of the documentary about
the eighties in miami and how fucking
crazy the cocaine world was.
Do you remember that shIt?
One of the things we've talked about was
that there was one year that were an
entire class of the police academy,
the graduating class.
All of them either wound up dead or
wound up in jail for corruption.
Really all the.
The whole police after a while where
they all just like tell the other ones
is how we do stuff.
I'm like,
all right,
this is way.
It's done well.
Especially the money amount of money
that's involved in cocaine in miami and
the eighties.
It must've been fucking completely
crazy.
There's a lot of good cops.
Most cops are good cops.
The problem is,
look,
there's most people are great.
You knoW,
most people that I meet day to day in my
life are,
are fine folk.
There's only occasionally one or two
people out of a vast majority that suck
and those stand out and you go off.
Fucking people suck.
But for the most part,
look in America and you know,
in a nice place like los angeles where
people are doing pretty good for the
most part.
I mean,
you know,
we're not starving to death.
People were pretty god damn nice.
It's pretty civil.
Most people are cool.
You know,
the majority,
the vast majority are cool,
but if a few of them are cons you'll
start going.
People are going to the same thing with
our so hard,
but it's like some do but some don't at
all.
You know,
one of what I was going to say about the
video where the cop was talking to the
guy and the guy wouldn't answer any
questions.
One of the things that was interesting
about it was a fucking together.
The cops were keeping him.
Well,
this count as being kind of shitty.
I was like,
I guess they knew they were being filmed
or something.
Yeah.
There was a little bit of that too,
because he had a camera and you're going
to get to the asking them where they're
pulling together.
Yeah.
Both the two cops,
his supervisor came over as well know,
you know,
but they're just trying to make sure
people aren't drunk.
You know,
love.
When they get caught with the camera
that's in their own car,
they were like,
you know,
that's their.
Yeah,
they're dumb and it's just like,
do you get so complacent that you just
feel like what you're doing is right?
I feel like they're gonna be able to
erase the evidence.
HoW old is this stuff?
I don't know.
It's probably a decade.
A decade old.
Do you think it works?
Yeah,
it tastes shitty.
Shitty.
But you think it's getting you high?
Probably still pretty high.
There's a place down the street that
used to be one of those,
um,
urgent care centers and now as a medical
marijuana place,
really not so urgent care.
He didn't,
wasn't a lot of money in that.
Now they prescribed we'd licenses to so
many of those billboards.
Were you driving around people who don't
live in la?
I have no idea.
What the fuck is going on here.
This pLace is correct.
There is maybe denver.
Denver's really close.
Dennis is just like this,
right?
Like there's a bunch of areas in dental
strip for the farmers is a place that
opened,
like they're opening across from each
other across,
from each other.
They're like there.
It's ridiculous.
It's one of the craziest things you've
ever experienced your life and it's one
of the reasons why so many of them are
getting shut down when people don't
realize how many of them there are.
When you hear about all these pot shops
getting shut down,
it's terrible.
The pot shops are getting shut down.
Absolutely.
It's terrible.
They're being prosecuted.
Especially the people that didn't even
do anything wrong.
There's a bunch of people that are being
unfairly targeted,
but there's also a bunch of dudes are
making a shitload of money.
Someone we'd.
They would have been in porn.
There's some people that it's like,
you can't even.
You can't even open a shoe store without
filling paperwork.
Yeah,
but they're like,
fuck it.
We're selling weed and you're like,
can't do that.
Doesn't give You a license to do
nothing.
Like our douchey friend that we were
talking about that left his job and now
is making tons of money selling weed.
It's like he's no shining light of
psychedelic live.
He's like,
he's a farmer,
he's a.
He's a.
He's a farmer.
What's cool is that place that's an ad
next to the ice house,
you can actually rent a space and grow
weed there.
Oh,
and they gave you chemicals that go real
cooperate.
Yeah.
It's like a place for rent and grow your
own shit.
Community gardens,
but only for a week or so.
Dope to America.
Yeah.
We're going to have to have those guys
come on the show,
but I don't know if they want to go
public works guys.
The guys from that place,
from that community garden as a run that
place.
We'll have them come on with anonymous
masks.
You ask him.
It's like,
do you want to.
Do you want to do it?
Here's what.
I wouldn't do it.
If I was them,
I'd want to stay as low key as an owner.
I know.
Look what you break down everything
because.
No,
no,
I couldn't.
No,
I don't want to call tHat kind of
attention to me.
Yeah.
You don't want anybody looking at you as
the target because like I had that guy
from oaksterdam and an oakland.
He doesn't mind.
He likes being a public spokesman.
Yeah,
but I mean,
haven't they gone after him a bunch of
times?
Probably.
I think there's a big issue right now
with um,
their,
what they're allowed to write off.
Like it's not like a regular business.
They're not allowed to write off,
they won't take tax on it.
So I thought that's we're just trying to
make illegal legal to take taxes,
but they don't take,
they must be taking some taxes from
medical weed.
I think it's a huge form of tax revenue,
isn't it?
Medical weed.
I know they said they on their own.
They said we're going to pay taxes,
let's find a medical marijuana tax.
Taxation tax revenue.
What about in like are they now paying
tax because I have to.
Or are they just doing it because they
let's find out.
Oh,
I'm here.
It's still.
And voters approve it.
Okay.
So they had to approve it.
This is what it is.
Voters had to approve marijuana tax.
Revenue measure measure.
Sixty percent of voters decided tuesday
to honor measure m,
a city.
What major am who am with a citywide
ballot measure that imposes new taxes on
the sales of medical marijuana at brick
and mortar dispensary's?
It allows city tax,
brick and mortar dispensary's $50 out of
each one.
Thousand in gross reimbursements.
So that's five percent.
$50 out of $100,
isn't it?
It's five percent.
Yeah.
So how much will they already get?
Five percent is what their taxes.
That's pretty good.
Sales tax is eight point two.
five data.
It's on top of that I think.
Oh really?
Think this is a city tax.
Marijuana,
los angeles,
marijuana tax,
whatever man.
Pay the tax you get in to make a fucking
shitload of money and you're spreading
that love.
Pay the tax.
That's what I would say.
They're making plenty of money or they
are a little bit less hollywood lawyer.
Prices a little already.
Just stepped up.
I feel are just starting to get out of
hand.
Receives a joke.
Tell me,
tell me.
Pharmacies are $75 for an eighth and
it's not that good.
It's like good.
It's good.
Homeboy sold me an ounce for how much
was it to 60?
To 50 to 50.
Shit puts you straight up.
That's my favorite.
That's my favorite with his oji.
Kush is just the greatest.
Yeah,
you bypass the stores,
but I.
I support the stores because I want to
be able to go to them.
It makes sense.
I know that if I go straight to the
grower,
you're going to be a lung support.
Great weed smoker.
That guy gives you on wholesale prices.
Yeah.
I don't need to make that money that
bad.
I would.
I would rather give that extra 100 bucks
or whatever to the store so that they
can make some profit and they can keep
open.
I like to conduct.
Can't make a profit that I supposedly.
They're not allowed to make profit,
but yeah,
I just read something like that.
They were like,
that's completely wrong.
Is it that just read that where they're
like,
that's absolutely wrong.
That's just a misinterpretation that
this rule.
I just read something.
It's in the recent.
Like web,
huh?
Yeah.
Was on dick.
I thought they weren't allowed to make
profit,
but they were allowed to be like,
all right,
you're getting paid $30 an hour.
You weight goes is you're not allowed to
make profit like a normal corporation
would,
but would.
The way you can do it is you can take a
salary,
you know,
like say if you run the place,
you could take a salary which is
commensurate for someone who would be in
your type of business so you could make
a salary of $100,000
a year and weigh a ton.
Mccormick was telling me one of the
things that they do is,
especially at osha damn guy,
they funnel a lot of the money back into
the community and the source of a
charity and the in the form of charity
in the form of grants.
They do a lot of different things with
their money and the guy who runs it
takes a salary,
pays all the employee's salary,
but you're not allowed to strictly get
rich off it.
You can't make.
It's not like the guy who owns it can
make 60 percent of the profits.
You can make as much as you want.
Really?
There wasn't nothing else.
Not wIth mccormick was telling me.
He was telling me he can't.
Fuck.
I wish I could.
He was telling me that you have to have
it,
you have to,
you take a salary and that's how it
works.
That's what your profit is.
just your salary and you know,
you could,
but you could still,
you know,
a salary for a business that size,
like what's,
what is commensurating a few hundred
thousand dollars a year.
I'm sure you know,
I mean if you were running,
you haul fucking empire,
you would,
you know,
which is dealing with the same amount of
money or something.
You halls a terrible example,
but you know what I'm saying?
You'd make a good,
good chunk of change.
You know,
a ceo for some big fucking company makes
a lot of goddamn money.
If you're a ceo for some giant
collective that's
responsible for millions of dollars
worth of business every year,
you should be gettIng paid well,
right?
Yeah.
Well that's what the ceos of the banks
did.
There's rules,
there's rules,
there's not enough rules as far as like
protecting the environment and too many
rules when it comes to everything else.
God daMn twat rockets.
It got a psvt joe.
This came out yesterday.
It's actuallY,
it doesn't come out until the 22nd.
Is this a video game?
But this is the new thing all the kids
are talking about.
It's a new game boy,
new playstation thing and it's going to
get into it.
ToUch screen on the back and the front
back.
it's got three g building a back is just
has a panel in.
It's just touch sensitive.
So like,
yeah,
so you can use with your steering.
Well and it's also got double joysticks
and check this out.
It's got touch screen in the front
finally.
Uh,
it's pretty cool.
I've only got to play with it a little
bit today.
I have an unboxing video,
death squad,
that tv doing a review.
It's called the psvt.
And,
and what kind of games you get into this
sucker.
What school is it?
The graphics are amazing,
like they look like a home console video
game and you can do your netflix on here
and since it has three g you can do all
the,
all the stuff that you can do,
like on a tablet,
it has two cameras and surf the web on
the camera front and the back and
everything was about her life.
I batteries about five and a half hours.
Six hours.
Uh,
it's,
it's pretty bad ass though.
It just came out.
It comes out the 22nd.
But you can buy an early version of it.
They send you one early.
I ordered.
They have a early,
like four people that preordered it.
You can get a weaker noises making
stupid song the hedgehog.
Now shut that stupid shit off.
Said.
Oh,
I don't know how to turn it off.
that's ridiculous.
Like there's a lot of stuff.
So.
Cool.
Why would the music be so stupid?
Oh,
here we go.
Medical marijuana profit is allowed
under California law.
should I read it?
Sure.
Fuck your wife ever eventually when it
loads up,
but yeah,
I'm doing a review on it.
A deaTh squad that was a fun so far.
It's pretty awesome.
And I like has,
has three g and you don't have any
contracts so you can just pay as you go.
Uh,
the cameras not that good,
but the graphics,
the screens amazing.
The gains are amazing.
You could download any,
a lot of the previous console.
So nowadays are kind of switching to
where you download your video games.
IT's still bind to the store.
Oh really?
Oh that makes sense.
So instead of,
so instead of getting a district,
you just download it and you just
download it and then you can delete it
if you want to,
you can delete it or whatever.
The only negative really going to get
rid of this.
So you,
that's going to be.
Everything's going to be in a cloud
downloads I guess.
I like that though.
my learn loan for a quarter phone hEr,
I want to go bad.
I'll do it man.
I don't want everything in the cloUd.
I do like the cloud.
If they do it right,
like itunes just recently switched over
to doing it right where it shows you all
the purchase cd songs that you've ever
downloaded on itunes and you can
look it and you could read down to 100
gigabytes of total songs.
Oh,
are you allowed to talk about what
happened in Minnesota?
Yeah.
Yeah,
because I only know pieces of this.
Are you sure?
Because I have to leave out.
Right.
There was a,
a thing that ari shaffir does.
It's all a lark.
I mean he pretends that what he's doing
is hiding marijuana all around town and
then he calls it a hunt for the edible
when it's really just lollipops candy.
Who wouldn't do that to you?
You can't handle it.
It would be.
It would be cute if you can handle it,
but you can't handle it.
So that said,
but coincidentally I do live in a state
where they could sell a really small
stuff all the time.
Right.
But anyone pretty much here,
it's not legal for us here.
Yeah.
So yeah.
So what happened?
So yeah,
I've had them before,
but I had little scavenger hunts for
this clearly fake only tobacco product.
I'm noT marijuana.
Whatever you think it is,
just to see if you got high from it.
Placebo effect.
It's really easy with diabetes.
But man,
I got dizzy.
Yeah,
it's fun.
People just made some clues and people
just find it.
And you have been organizing this
through twitter.
It seems like a solid plan.
Well it's good that you're not using
real pot because it's totally fucking
heart attacks and freak the fuck out
did.
So you did this.
So usually I do them not in a,
in a specific type of place,
you know,
just do them somewhere like out.
Right.
I did it this time.
I tried doing at the mall of America
don't like fort knox.
Yeah,
it's all locked down now.
I guess they have their own security and
they have regular police there too.
And so what happened?
Well,
I uh,
I decided instead of hiding it,
like in the outside,
like near a pillar or something,
I figured there'd be less cameras.
So I should go into a store and hide
their increased business for them.
Right.
And so I did that,
the store grubbY hippies out looking for
fucking free.
We'd also like,
what kind of clues can I go,
like,
what's it around that I can think of a
clue for.
Um,
and then I found a place and then I
left,
it was like good a building boom that I
waited for,
like,
you know,
a few hours,
started writing the clues and then I
started releasing them.
It was great.
And people that are looking for it first
I narrowed down like a side of the mall,
then like a floor and then like the
store then like where?
Anyway,
so the show would just order.
The mc was on.
I was texting outside and um,
and uh,
I just saw a cop to my right to my left
just standing there and they're like,
alright.
And I was like,
I looked up and I was like,
oh fuck,
this is happening now.
I really didn't think it would.
Yeah.
And I'm like,
fuck.
They're like,
we're gonna talk to you for.
I'm like,
oh,
hey,
is totally cool,
but somebodies got to go inside right
now.
Just let them know that I'm in trouble
because they're gonna have to find
somebody like really soon,
like the show just started like,
I'm like 40 minutes to find someone to
live nearby in minneapolis there.
Just let them know that this is
happening.
So they did whatever the cop,
let's just say,
let's just say he was cool.
um,
so he didn't find any specific evidence.
Um,
so that wasn't a problem,
but the ball security was trying to say
I couldn't go on,
they're going to ban me from the mall
and the club is in the mall.
Oh yeah.
And then rick brunson,
the owner had to get on the phone and
start yelling at them saying,
who the fuck are you going to cost me
money because that idiot fucking hide
pot somewhere and hide fake pot.
That's when he called you an idiot.
He said,
yeah,
to the security.
It's like,
you're not going to cost me a bunch of
money and refunds and disappoint all
those people because he wants to be
fucking moron.
Wow.
I explain that.
What happened to you?
Like what is it?
I'M like,
it's just for fun.
It's where I'm,
where I go.
It's totally legal.
It's just I want other people to have
fun even though it's fake.
It was fake.
Fake.
Yes.
But I think they,
they understood that.
They're like,
you can't even do that in California
because it's only legal with a license
and you don't have a kid's going to
grab.
It isn't illegal.
That's the thing.
It's decriminalized in California to a
certain amount as long as you don't
think you're distributing it.
So some people have said,
what happens to a 15 year old gets it?
I'm like,
yeah,
he gets high.
Great time for them.
What do you mean there's no problem?
They're pretty sure the kid's going to
have to take these kids who got them
came the next day to the show did.
Oh,
well,
lucky it wasn't really we'd.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
What happened was,
uh,
the people who went to the underwear,
I'll have that,
have that store,
but I shouldn't say because that labor
is pretty cool too.
Um,
uh,
I'm going to go on a limb and say it was
still say her story.
She was cool.
She was like,
I'm not going to press charges.
Please take that any mentioned on my
store so I don't get in trouble.
Okay.
So because it was a male clothing store,
I wanted to hide it,
a lane bryant at a fabric store,
but I didn't think I'd get in there
without being noticed as well.
Like why would it even be in there?
Because you look like something that
would date a fat person.
Do you really think it looks like
someone who did some ways if the world
gets dark?
Um,
yeah.
So the first one went and got it and the
underwear and the next principal came in
and they couldn't find it.
So I start tearing everything up,
like looking for it.
That was an unintended consequence.
That sucks.
Yeah.
But no trouble.
They let me off like five minutes before
I go on.
Oh,
that's good.
Yeah.
Did you go on stage immediately?
Talk about it?
Of course you did.
It's the first thing I met with
everybody.
I'm just,
um,
I was just a.
Yeah,
and he got on the phone with me.
They were like,
he wants to talk to you on the phone
because he was in edmonton on his land
line and he was like,
hey,
first thing's first,
you need to act like I'm yelling at you.
Okay,
so now is your smile.
Got.
And I was like,
yeah.
And I started laughing.
Don't laugh,
don't laugh.
I'm serious.
He goes,
it's not going to be any problem at all.
I'm like,
sorry dude,
for cutting here because I don't fucking
care.
It's totally cool.
I think if you've been running a comedy
club,
he's also a comic.
No,
it's totally fine.
Yeah,
you got to be careful.
That's crazy.
So don't fold.
Repercussions.
Got to be fucking careful.
That shit's superly illegal in certain
parts of this country and we don't
realize it because as we sit here,
even though that's another lane once
doing,
it's just
so lame.
So you knitting is taking liquid acid
in.
Squirting it into.
Don't imagine if you did the best that I
was standing there with security and
some people came up for the late show or
something and they're like already
brought something for you and they will
open up the purse.
I was like,
no,
no.
But then she was like,
it's okay.
I'm like looking at like,
don't know.
There was a swedish fish.
So those are just some like gumby
product.
Oh,
that's delicious.
I offered it to the cops and the lady
cop was super hot.
Really like super high.
How high I was high.
What?
how hot?
Like an la h.
Wow.
Like legit.
Like I kept looking at her and I was
like,
you guys should come in and just totally
should come in.
He tried to get her to come to the show.
I've been trying.
I couldn't go fully.
Like so when you get off we should hang
out.
Totally.
Conrad.
I regret not doing it.
She was so pretty.
It was a little worried.
Maybe she's starving.
Intellectual conversatIon.
A funny guy.
Great sense of humor.
She seemed like she got it too.
Try to keep the handle or maybe she was
dating the other really nice cop guide
and thrown you and praising you.
Probably.
Fuck.
So every time they shoot somebody,
that's the deal.
Don't shoot people down then.
Dude,
shit gets crazy.
Do you remember the mall cop?
she wasn't even a real.
It wasn't a real tough.
She was part of the mall cop.
She was so pretty man.
I was like,
you guys should have a comment.
We should responsive at all to you.
She would smile.
She knew that it was just something
being an idiot.
The guy mall cop was trying to pretend
like it was a bad ass,
but he couldn't really keep it going
that much.
Head of security was trying to really
enforce the law,
but who fucking cares?
You get in trouble,
but I could've.
Could've wenT to jail.
You know what,
if somebody just showed up the joint,
so this dirty jew gave me this joint.
I can say that now and I smoked it.
Whoa.
Don't stop doing that.
We're going to have be real from cypress
hill on soon.
Oh,
that's cool.
I've been going back and forth with them
on twitter and arch barker.
He's going to be on to one of the things
about.
Yeah,
he's in America to monday.
One of the things about a be real from
cypress hill that he and I shared that
he won't just take weed from strangers.
He won't.
He won't feel it there.
We'd benefit from everybody.
Yeah.
Doug benson does.
He gets involved but the government is
probably getting high with them too and
they're probably some some ways we just
got like little gps signals in that.
That's all you get high off at this
point.
Tolerance too high off gps.
Gps crystals.
Getting high off wifi.
Didn't be hard.
How about how long before they actually
just spray you with some shit they can
track you with?
Probably pretty.
Probably already have the capabilities.
We already have the idea that they can
track it already.
Yeah,
I mean it's hard to find you just
through your role on the grid.
Yeah.
Twitter,
you're going to go going to burbank
about the airport should go about your
business.
They don't care what you do most of the
time.
Most of the time until you oppose them,
until you're ready to take over.
Can you imagine the kind of taPping they
have on ron paul's information?
He
can't even order a pizza without them
breaking down the word.
And hoW long is the aardvark bar going
to be here for him?
He said til monday.
okay.
Amazing.
So ignoring this ron paul cat and then
pushing this rick santorum,
dude on everybody.
Well,
at least it's not a mormon.
There's been evidence of voter fraud in
main.
By the way,
ron paul supposed to the one in Maine
and they were uh,
before even all the precincts were
counted,
they were giving it to santorum.
They're saying is voter fraud and made
really.
I mean it's just a have to do.
I'm paula when,
once the prelims.
Well,
you know what man,
I think this whole system is rigged.
Of course it is really,
absolutely,
absolutely.
Truly believe it.
And I think these guys are just
auditioning to be the ceo of a company
or they're not even going to get a
chance to say what the fuck gets to go
on and they're not going to get it
anyway.
Obama's gonna win again.
A ball was way better than mitt romney.
He's way more charismatic.
He can look,
they can do some hollywood math and the
numbers and have you convinced that
we're in an epipen economic,
that he to the rich.
Yeah.
He came in the wrong time and the world
that the world was fucked up when he got
here and the country was fucked up,
but in the time that he's been here held
spins and puking the legislation that
we've passed and help this and the
economic stimulus and a.
The things sort of whatever that
national defense authorization act kills
everything that he did.
Everything.
That's that thing that allows people to
be detained indefinitely with no
warrants.
The fact that he passed that like it's
just such an easy way to abuse the so
gross.
It's gross.
It's consistently on my radio station
that comes on like the news about the.
About the,
about the elections have predilections
wherever they're happening.
It just seems like when newt gingrich
and perry and santorum and all the other
mitt romney,
it seems like to keep like just lying
and then like going back on.
Yeah,
I did say this,
but that's not what I believe now.
It just seems like a little kids thing.
Whatever they can so they can get their
prize,
but it's like enron,
paul's and just as well,
this is what I believe.
A lot of this shit's not popular.
Give me another one of those.
Good,
but it's like,
this is what I've always said the same
thing for always.
Yeah.
When they're afraid of going on the
record for what they really believe.
If it's not popular,
it's real.
They don't believe shit.
They just leave.
They want to be president.
Like they're just trying to get elected.
It's like when you auditioned for a show
that you hope you don't get.
Yeah.
We're like,
this sucks,
but like I'll put.
I'll make believe humor.
Rick perry is so lucky.
He's dumb because now he gets to live
the rest of his life without secret
service agents wiping his ass everywhere
he goes,
because if he won and he could have
fucking one,
don't get me wrong if that guy.
I auditioned for the role of president
just four years ago.
Okay.
And he was just coached a little bit
better and some more little hindsight
prepared some.
Yeah.
You get some smart dudes behind him.
It is attracting the best pr people.
He's no dumber than earlier.
He's no dumber than gw.
It's just like an actress just to build
your resume,
build your resume,
do it correctly.
Unpopular at the right time.
Exactly.
He was popular one point in time.
Do you remember?
It was like that guy was like,
he lOoked handsome,
looked lIke fucking,
but I rather than talking about obama
at some like democratic convention and
they're like,
oh,
he gave a really good speech.
People are gonna.
Look at him noW.
It's like a presidential guy.
It's like having a really good game and
the nba all star game.
it's like having a good set on,
on comedy central and all of a sudden
it's like,
oh,
watch out.
YeAh,
it's an awesome chick.
It's a movie.
Yeah.
I remember my,
um,
my friend who I will not name his name
because he's a silly,
silly fucking liberal.
Not there's anything wrong with being a
liberal,
but he's silly.
He's just one of those guys and when I,
they believe it too much.
I am very liberal and most of the
things,
most things I can't marriage and civil
rights and most of those things.
But um,
shouldn't be attached to everything
though.
Exactly.
I'm not on a team.
I'm not on team.
This team that.
And when you are,
I think you're silly if you're a liberal
by choice,
you know,
like,
in a category predetermined pattern
behavior your fall or your conservative,
either one of them is just silly to me.
But this guy was like telling me like
what a great president obama would make.
And I go,
why do you say that?
What policies that he supports,
do you,
do you believe he didn't have a fucking.
Nothing to say.
He just started giving me like
doubletalk.
I go,
do you eveN know this?
Anything that stuff this guy does or do
you love him because he's a good looking
black guy and know the love,
lIke supporting a black guy because
you're.
You got a little bit of white guilt and
he didn't want to administer howard
stern thing they did where they
interview people and just messed up the
facts like obama,
obama,
mccain is running together against
someone.
Who are you going to vote for obama or
mccain?
Oh no,
I'm okay.
Do you think would be a good buy present
for obama was like,
yeah,
I like his policies.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
Yeah.
Was it,
was it.
I'm trying to remember who that fuck
that was good at.
Maybe it's a tough crowd.
Fuck,
I wish I knew what it was.
It was.
Who's that guy?
We met him in New York that time.
The boston common boston comic.
I'm like me.
I was telling nick depaulo.
Yeah.
I think what I was texting or something.
No,
no,
that's not what it was you.
You joked around about jocks.
He said something about john boston is
all jocks.
That's good.
Yeah.
That's what you said.
A bunch of dumb jocks fuckers just
cracked.
Nick dipaolo is quick to tell you the
word sweater or something and I was
like,
oh,
well kids,
we all kept below.
What do you think?
what the venture?
Yeah.
He thought,
well,
you kind of dress a little bit like a
hipsteR.
Yeah,
I guess they do and people that didn't
know you,
they would totally think you're a
hipster until you hear you talk.
Anything alternative comic,
a filthy dirty mouth on stage.
Yeah.
they would take your alternative.
Thank god you're not just so hard to be
friends with an alternative comment.
I can pretend that all that shit is
funny.
It's starting to go away.
The lines,
of course it is some real good people
that just go up in that scene and then
vice versa.
It just comics.
yeah,
of course it is the the people that
wanted to be alternative.
They literally used to always do that.
Yeah,
but they all rooms and he goes to the
store and you're like,
oh,
you come here to him.
It's like,
what do you mean six times?
Yeah.
He's just a comic.
Yeah,
he's smart enough to realize that,
but a lot of these dummies,
they.
It was like,
you know what?
we found a cool club.
This is like the cool kids club is the
janeane garofalo club.
Chechen rebel.
Doesn't that sound like a serial church?
Me?
Yeah.
What would you say that?
Because that's really low line because
he was looking.
I think he was imagining her doing.
I'm doing what they do on stage and sang
something mildly ironic.
You know?
It's not even funny.
Shot at not funny.
No.
Work harder.
You're not trying hard enough.
Then you,
your point of view sucks because it's
not real.
You're not really.
You're just trying to fit into a mold
that you think these little hipster twat
heads are gonna.
Appreciate.
Clap,
clap.
I saw paul,
tom because talking about the state of
alternative comedy podcasts in san
francisco,
jamie kilstein,
his estate,
his aides.
He goes,
it's really sucky right now.
He's always people trying to Be
alternative comics and sucky because
they're trying to be this instead of
just being.
It's aids,
aids,
aids.
It's not funny and they're super snotty
about it.
It's like the thing about the grossest
thing,
snotty,
snotty nose,
overwatch,
it's you're not even putting out good
art,
like shut your mouth.
It's not good stuff.
It's not funny.
You know the.
The bottom line is it was created.
Some of it is.
Yeah,
but that's good comedy period.
Good.
Anywhere there.
The bottom line is the need for
alternative comedy was created because
the ones who were trying to do it
weren't successful in other rooms.
They weren't successful.
Whether it's because they're performing
for dme crowns or whether it's
performing for people that didn't
appreciate what they were doing,
so they had to find people who did.
That's all well and good,
but they became an a lot of ways.
Not all of them.
Totally generalizing and pigeon holing
irony,
this ironic disposition.
They also became like sort of comedy
bullies to,
you know,
like if you hung around them like bert
kreischer is a terrible story about them
being fucking shitty to him over the uc,
whatever it is.
Do you see being about how gross was
experienced?
Was there.
Because when people are bullied,
they want to bully back,
you know,
children that are molested go onto
become a lester's.
So weird.
But then ian edwards,
I've met him in like my mobile
connection.
I did call me on it,
like whatever.
Just keep talking stupid,
keep rambling and go with an
alternative.
I'm like,
what material do for this?
It goes crowds and crowds,
man.
yeah,
I've done it twice and had great crowds.
Yeah,
I did the ucb.
I loved it.
I had a great time now,
but the audiences,
it's a comic artists and it's not all of
them.
It's just a few of them.
It's just like cops,
a few cuts spoil the whole pockets.
What it is,
that's what it is,
what it is.
Exactly what it is.
That's why everyone's against them.
Because those few cons.
Yeah,
and same with cops.
Same with girls.
You know,
same with guys,
you know,
same with everything.
The few people on this,
I don't think congress anymore because
all the comments that have been bad.
I'm like,
come on,
wait,
break it down because I'm not all of
them.
Yeah,
but you're terrible.
Yeah.
But if it's like all about like whatever
it is,
I'm like,
yeah,
we did that.
Just like I'm gonna give you a chance.
But if they say they're needy,
then I'm like,
well I'm not needy,
but I like the kick mit.
I'm like,
oh yeah.
Right.
That's fine.
Yeah,
we shouldn't do
it.
Yeah.
Well isn't that what all women want?
Arash fear that some of them down one
love,
they'll want to know that you're going
to be there for them.
They all want you to listen to their,
their highlight reel,
highlight reel director act worse,
dating a comic dating comic and you have
to help them with their act.
Do you think this is funny?
There's nothing more of a turn off the
grill going over her bits with you.
Anyone going over the bits with
horrible.
Yeah,
but a girl that you want to fuck and
she.
Okay.
Stop it.
I want.
I want you to listen to my.
Listen to my child.
Tell me things.
It's funny.
I mean dick is like a headache and your
pants don't,
don't,
don't.
Let's just do it.
And they just want tell me,
tell me the things.
This is good.
I've dated a few callbacks.
I started telling him now it's like,
I am not going to help you with your
act.
I'm not going to try to correct you.
If I see something like thematically
you're doing that,
I can see a fixed for like you should
check out this room.
Might do.
Well they're like,
I will do that,
but that's it.
Let's just give you suggestions of like
directions to go.
Yeah.
I go to peers.
There is something wrong with this bit
man who's going to bid?
Feeding scene too verbose or something
like that.
I kind of just sounding off.
I kind of know anyway.
If you're being objective about your
shit,
which always has.
Somebody tells you they saw that.
Like,
I liked that joke.
I'm like,
do you think?
Yeah,
it's actually take it in there.
It needs a little some or you know,
they saw it.
You kind of know though,
you know,
when something needs something,
if you're being really honest about it.
Right.
But sometimes they help you.
They're like,
well,
have you ever thought about going from
there into your,
like your family right there and you're
like,
oh,
I didn't know you were reading comics.
They're not writing you a joke.
They're just like an angle.
You didn't.
Yeah,
yeah.
Or good taglines or yeah.
I had this king kong bit that I was
doing and a louis ck pulled me aside.
He goes,
you know,
it was really funny.
You should say that.
Cognizance really wife too.
And like do this thing.
Look king kong's d wife at home.
Why this whole thing about king kong
being like the most racist movie ever?
You kNow that he was around these naked
black women his entire life.
He never gave a fuck.
He saw one white chick and address and
lost his fucking mind.
It had to have her,
you know,
mean really exactly what that movie was.
They were dancing.
these black girls,
they had feathers on shit.
They were taking their tits,
hanging out,
drums,
playing fire dance and shit.
No one cared and he's like,
hey,
should I can congress and wife?
That was why he was still married
though.
That's lIke the angle you always go to
see what holds them back.
it keeps them from being funny comic
again.
A casually.
They told me that sometimes.
I think that again today,
yesterday.
Do you really stinking.
Oh my gosh.
Natasha again.
Damn heavy.
So weird.
Did you even fucking imagine you guys
just swapped back and forth and you're
like,
look,
I know you left me before.
But uh,
I wasn't a man that I am now.
I'm a different man now.
I think it was totally
cool.
Was totally cold back then when you went
with duncan,
you just go right to me.
One second you blog and then as soon as
you pull out,
you net it right in her eyes and say,
fuck you.
I've been waiting for five years to do
this.
Fuck you.
And give her a double fingers while
you're naked.
Fuck how many guys had done that,
got back with a girl.
Pretend to be in love with that,
just so they could shoot a little bit.
I can do that.
And then just just say,
fuck.
You ever see that old movIe called the
the,
the era.
It's about this girl who got jilted and
she goes,
well boy,
it's to get revenge for like decades.
That's like I spit on your grave.
Yeah.
I have grossed out that weight on like
just to box and lindsey low and I think
in like 12 years.
And they would probably be doable once
they hit the wall.
You know who I think you can get you.
Brett butler from grace under fire.
A place to stay right there.
You can take my face bright.
But she talked about her and back on the
last show about how crazy it was that
she was one of the chuck lorre.
She was a chuck lorre show.
Grace under fire.
That guy has just been around forever.
Just turn them out,
the hIts.
And she,
uh,
she was all cracked out and she said
there was always the,
um,
the rumor on the success that she had
done some crazy thing,
threw a drink in his face and he got,
she got gone from that.
Yeah.
Powerful is,
fuck you think he cares that you're
ready to twelfth.
Uh,
you're not supposed to do that.
A lot of money.
You're not supposed to do that.
Anyway,
that's what killed titus is show to ever
turn something down for money.
Like somebody offers a spot to this and
you're like,
that doesn't go with what I do at all.
Oh yeah,
definitely.
It's like people can turn down money.
Chuck lorre says I don't need,
I have plenty of money.
You just can't.
I'll just not do your show or kill your
show before it goes to cindy.
You're going to be a complete asshole to
me than you know.
I'm not going to work for you if it
kills you.
that tituss show.
But fairly syndication.
Yeah.
He had some crazy blowout.
Maybe that tv show.
I talked about it a few times,
but no one could remember it.
It's called Mr.
Smith.
It was about a monkey monkey.
Vice president.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And it's in black and white.
No,
no,
no.
That's your thing that Mr.
Smith goes to Washington.
Well this is a tv show aNd somebody
uploaded a,
like five second commercial on youtube
the other day and so I finally sent me.
So I find.
So I finally found a.
I have a screenshot of that monkey,
so I don't know if I'm going crazy.
That's an orangutan.
They hang a tank guy.
This is what it looked like.
He,
he was the president and it was some
kind of animated or a muppet realistic
muppet type alf type thing.
Oh.
So it Was a.
Wasn't there wasn't a real.
Do they use both?
it sounds like when nbc went to 7:30
prime time,
small,
small wonder I think was there was nbc
also my two dads.
IT was nbc.
Yeah.
It seemed like.
And they're all way worse than a regular
sitcoms.
Sitcoms.
A shitty.
Think what?
Wouldn't have made it right here.
I want to read this about the cannabis
thing.
Okay.
There's the robert raich who wrote it.
There's a widely held misconception that
businesses in California medical
cannabis industry are prohibited from
making a profit.
In realiTy,
no California law prohibits cannabis
related businessman for making a profit.
Opponents of metal pot.
I'm going to translate as I read it.
However,
I've done a masterful job spreading
disinformation since sb four.
20 was signed into law in 2003.
The disinformation has become so
prevalent that is affecting safe access
to medical cannabis patients,
blah,
blah.
Okay,
and is it resulted in state senator
john,
whatever releasing a letter debunking
the why,
the health medical reception,
that part,
that profit is not permitted for medical
cannabis providers under California law.
Looking at brian's moth,
the giant moth,
he smoked and just moved.
It's shit.
Why would you smoke?
Something that came out of that liquid
looks so trippy that I'm like,
I wonder if this would do anything.
I mean,
it didn't look like a fucking poison.
It was probably poop or something.
It's probably lit it anyway.
Poison.
It's probably it.
You know what it is?
It probably had had a miscarriage right
there oN your floor.
Yeah,
I bet it was pregnant.
I bet that was pregnant.
Could be because they might look like to
for two days.
Yeah.
Jesus christ.
Brian,
you got to die.
It's not good.
Whatever it is is not good.
You have like one of those ports on
trees where,
where it goes over,
we can stay in the room if you won't get
what?
Yeah.
What did mouth love that?
Here?
It's finally talking today.
Bob.
Was both of those just downloading it
this way?
Are those your balls?
Huh?
Oh,
there's your balls.
No,
they're pretty.
If they are,
can you imagine if you got an operation
to have your balls always in the shape
of a heart.
It was a new thing and women wanted you
to do it.
I show them that you really cared and
yOu just get your balls tucked into a
heart shape.
Like they would.
Uh,
there was like a little plastic v
implant that they would put in at the
bottom of my heart.
I always wanted to do it.
I always want to wonder why,
like belly buttons never got like,
like getting an extended or Changed in
any way.
The balls are so vulnerable,
but nobody would touch it.
Sometimes they get bothered.
Button rings,
people,
girls get an implant on your balls with
like a wireframe.
That was like in the shape of a heart.
Like those ladies dresses from the old
days,
but I had to pool from out.
Yeah,
they're just spread it Out like a bat.
The bat wing over the balls and spread
it out into your fucking balls are
already super vulnerable.
If somebody kicks you in the balls and
you have an implant in their skin was
even hurt anymore,
but there's so much extra skin you can
do stuff with them so much.
Totally.
Well,
that's what we were talking about.
The guy who got fucked to death by the
horse.
He had like a whole binder.
A notebook binder.
Yeah,
of of rings.
Why not?
Of course it eventually will do that.
People will put it in the shape of a
heart.
That'd be sweet.
It'll be a cupcake maker.
Get girls to suck on them.
Swear you.
You'd keep your hard drive ways.
No,
that's not true.
Take your dick out.
Suck on your balls will suck on your
balls,
period.
The odds of it happening.
Yeah.
If a girl won't Suck on your balls,
you really shouldn't be with her.
I don't like it.
I think it tickles.
You got problems you,
it doesn't take
all you at all.
If a girl will suck on your balls.
Oh my girlfriend loves it.
That's basically polly's move.
He would take it out.
She'll do anything.
Just take it out just as.
Yeah.
And it would say like,
either they're going to do this or
they're not.
WE're going to find out right now.
Yeah.
But I mean,
girl,
you're dating.
Oh,
you didn't suck your balls.
Some girls won't suck balls.
They'll suck your dick.
But there's a line they won't cross.
There's girls that you can't come in
their mouth.
That's what she wants.
A alley was walking by and um,
and uh,
we were pretending.
I just had my balls out all the time,
right at the store.
Just all the time.
Just had my dick and balls out and we're
trying to get at the.
Commits this one girl to like,
no,
it's totally normal.
They smell fine,
you should just suck it.
Oh,
I remember this day and pretended like,
oh really?
Yeah.
I said like she didn't know me and she
was like,
hey,
what's going on?
Uh,
there's like,
do you know this guy is like,
know what's happening.
I love the comedy store.
It's so fun here.
They were like,
we're trying to explain like it's
totally cool.
Just these guys.
They're like,
oh yeah,
maybe I'll do it like we're together and
she says blowing outside and then she
would just walk out as you're trying to
convince this girl that is totally
normal.
Do you Have this on tape somewhere?
It was so weird and no one got
embarrassed for.
Was like,
yeah,
she does it.
She's with her.
Of course,
the girl said she was so confused by it.
She's like,
what is happening?
It was really funny.
This awesome.
Well,
that's pretty much easy.
Jesus.
She's,
oh no,
no.
Your ex's into jesus.
You need to have her on a skeptic tank.
Hold on,
hold on,
hold on.
When was the last time you talked to
her?
We text sometimes text.
What about in person?
But it's been about a year and a half in
that time she went to jesus.
Jesus.
How long ago did you break up to years?
Three,
four,
four or five?
No,
it was,
it was post the store.
We,
we just figured that out,
right?
That it's been five years since I went.
I quit going to the store a sick.
Well,
2007 was when I was in seventh.
So it was a.
Yeah,
because when all that stuff happened,
I had someone else that I think we'd
already broken up by the.
Wow.
So it's a five years ago.
Okay.
So a year and a half ago she got into
jesus,
something like that.
I'm not good with time.
Marijuana is definitely ruined that.
Is that a guy?
It's a guy that's.
No,
no,
no.
It's just like,
you know,
she didn't want to do whatever she was
doing for people find that jesus.
So then she started saying that you kind
of a sermon with me and I'm like,
stop,
you know,
it's all I can do.
Dr mok you.
But meanwhile she tried to get me to go.
Really intelligent.
That's weird.
She was a very intelligent person,
super smart people like like the jesus
all the time.
I don't quite get it.
I will.
I'll get her on that.
There's a harder.
They compartmentalize their logic is
what it is and the idea behind it is
great.
The idea behind me,
if it was real,
god damn it,
wouldn't it be beautiful?
Wouldn't it be beautiful?
They're really talking about need to
find jesus.
Have you found jeans?
But they.
They're not lying to you when they say
that,
it's because if you really do believe
that there's more fulfilled guess,
then it's
like,
I'm happy for you if you're happy,
but like she was in what she probably
wasn't happy have,
you know,
a lot of girls who do like,
they get wild and they like blow guys
the comedy store in front of people,
you know,
like that kind of behavior,
that kind of wild behavior.
That's fun.
If you'rE around people who think it's
fun,
but if you're not a you get judged by
enough people who don't think that shit
is funny and if you're the type of
person does like wild shit and tries to
be funny and has tries to have a good
time and it was a little impulsive,
people will fucking judge you and to the
point where you start to think that your
morals are really questionable and
you're a fucked up person.
You need to get your shit together and
if you hear that enough and you don't
have a support system,
you,
you'll crack more.
Let me think about it.
She's living with this guy.
I mean you're my friend.
You're here and everything like that,
but you're a brilliant guy.
Very,
very intelligent,
very educated,
very well read and your around her all
the time.
So you were having intelligent
conversations with her and if people
don't have that in their life,
if all of sudden they get cut off from
that and everyone just telling you,
dr.
Death,
morons,
and you're around a giant swarm of moron
influence and more on information.
I was talking to people in minneapolis
and they were like,
what would you rather have a of virgin
who's not good at sex or someone who's
very good effect,
but it had sex with a lot of people.
I'm like,
definitely the one that sucks.
A lot of people were talking about sex
with people and be like,
yep,
fine.
That's fine.
What are you talking about?
Of course,
who cares?
We gas.
What do you care?
So silly.
We get long season all diseased up.
Oh yeah.
Why don't she don't got a virgin?
I'm teaching teacher.
How did you like the virgin way?
Teach them how to do stuff.
She like,
I don't want you sweating.
I feel bad like an unbeliever.
I gave him.
Oh,
they're going to Cry and talk.
he's like a virgin and haley wasn't part
of their deal.
Yeah,
you definitely want to go with the slot,
but you don't want to go with the
crying.
Yeah.
You know the problem with the girls had
sex with a lot of people is a lot of
times they feel bad about it or they've
done it because there's some underlying
issue.
I think anyone I've been around a little
bit is like,
just seems like they're cool with sex.
We'll have sex and we feel like having
some of them.
Some of them,
yes and no.
I'm just saying the occasional bomb,
the occasional 110 that starts crying,
ruins all the rest of fun.
Girls.
Look at advisor.
She hates sex.
She's talks about hoW she notes having
sex to backers.
Everybody wants to find out why does she
hate it?
I don't know.
She's just as like a minute and a half.
I'm done.
I just wanted it to be to be over with.
It seemed super uncomfortable about a
lot of shit though.
She's a strange girl.
She's super aggressive,
real competitive.
Loves her dog.
Hold onto the dog too much.
She's really quick,
real quick and aggressive at the
ceremony on his birthday last night and
she didn't have her dog so I'm like
looking around interpersonal last night.
Like regular clothes high.
Yeah.
She changes in dress,
dress down before she goes on stage.
She has as a comic,
she's want to get judged by anybody
looking at or anything like that.
She's got a great body,
you put on a loose tee shirt and jeans
and then she goes back to the car,
gets into like nice clothes,
attractive clothes,
and then goes out with her.
I love sending her pictures of just
random black dicks actually react to
that.
She loves it.
She might be saving them up in a
portfolio for when you start getting
rich and she's going to fucking sue you.
You're right about that.
Yeah.
I worry about that.
One person I talked to him about sexual
harassment if you just do it to a
person,
right?
Yeah.
I don't man at this is this stupid,
scared,
loopy as fucking day in comics to
comics.
I think you're safe doing that,
you would think,
but I don't think it works that way.
The employee handbook for the lawyer
comedy store,
it said like,
uh,
you cannot say anything of a racial
manner to another employee.
You cannot say anything of a sexual
manner.
And other employee it was like all these
rules,
but it goes,
but then it goes.
With that being said,
you will hear from us stage some of the
worst imaginable language from any
human.
That doesn't matter.
You still can't act like that to other
employees.
You'll hear horribly thing saying,
super racist,
super sexist,
like every night.
Isn't that funny?
If you work there and you're like a
waiter and you try to be as funny as the
comedians,
the tee shirt on.
Yeah,
you'd go to jail.
They'll take eveRything.
It'll lawsuit.
Let's take everything that.
Fuck you cnn.
Here's an article,
george clooney still open to marriage.
Fuck.
They'll open America today in west
hollywood.
What?
Uh,
thIs guy started.
This is what I heard on the way here is
I don't know what the full story,
but the guy started,
this guy started walking around these
houses and I kicking people's doors in
and yelling and then,
uh,
he kicked somebody door down and then
caught the house on fire and shot three
people.
And I get 30 2:38
year old women and a 34 year old guy
today.
Explain that again.
What happened?
But he kicked sOmebody door down.
he started kicking the door down like
pneuMonia,
melrose,
and then he just started fucking
shooting people and then cotsen house on
fire,
but they were still figuring it out
while I was driving here and I go,
wow,
we don't know what's going on.
Wow.
That guy in Utah let his kids on fire.
No,
he killed him with a hatchet and blew
the house uP and then lit it on fire.
They blew the house.
Why I feel better about the he,
it's horrific.
I thought he just lit them all on fire
after bernadette.
It's terrible.
What he did was they,
a social worker came that was supposed
to babysit him while he's with the kids
supposed to be there,
he's not supposed to have.
And then they ran into the house.
He grabs them,
pulls them,
and pushes the guy out,
kills the kids with a hammer.
The guy opens a door,
is smells gas,
and then the,
uh,
the guy who kills the kids with a
hatchet rather blows up the house and
kills all of them because if you can't
have them,
no one can.
I don't knoW what the reason.
He lost custody.
He'd killed the wife.
He killed.
He had killed a white and he killed the
wife and he was under suspicion of it
and while he was under suspicion,
they pornography
questionable pornography on his
computer.
I heard it was what it was was he didn't
love his wife because he had worn.
It was child porn,
but it was animated.
Was animated child porn.
It's so weird.
I didn't think they had.
This is by the way,
the third hand,
third hand information.
Do you have the jerry sandusky was
trying to gain the right to go onto his
back porch.
Oh,
he was going on his back porch and while
he was there he was looking at an
elementary school
in elementary school and that's where he
lives.
So we can look at an elementary school
that wasn't even part of the beginning.
Part of the story,
right?
He's a monster.
That guy's a fucking mom.
He wants.
He wants a chance to see his grandkids
so we can have one more before it goes
away.
It's so crazy that that guy got as far
as taste,
when you hear him talk about it,
it's scary.
It's just the way he talked about it.
Are you attracted to children?
My attracted to children.
That's how he answered that.
He didn't say no,
no,
no.
Stop.
No,
no,
of course not.
What I think he might be struggling with
it really,
really hard.
Oh god.
Really say that.
Almost everybody that is in that sort of
a situation.
Yeah.
Got molested when they were young.
That's how.
That's how those people reproduce.
Isn't that?
That's their method of reproduction.
Fucking crazy thing.
He's nuts.
That you can imprint that into a child's
mind.
you.
I don't think it's 100 percent sure the
space has moved on.
There's a lot of people to get molested
that don't wind up doing that and they,
you know,
it's like people who are around when
their father beats their mother.
Some people they grow up to beat their
wife as well.
It becomes.
Or if your.
If your parents beat you,
you beat your kids and some of them it's
the opposite way.
They liked the snow land.
It depends if you like it.
Like,
like when I got molested by that
babysitter I,
she was totally and I loved it.
That's totally different.
You like what,
how will they be like 10 or 11?
And she was a chick and she was pretty
and that was fun for me.
I'm such a difference between a guy
doing that to a little kid and a girl
doing that to a little kid.
Right.
So I don't want some chick blowing my
kids,
you know,
I wouldn't want to come home and some
fucking hot chick is blowing a 10 year
old boy.
I wouldn't want to see that.
That would be fucked up and you would
have to call the cops and everything.
But man,
it would be the only thing that would be
traumatic as the poor guy would probably
be in love with her.
You know,
you know when you.
She's my favorite babysitter.
Why can't you hire her anymore?
She was telling other ones.
Now I'm friends with her on facebook
because I hunted her down.
I want to marry her.
I want to play older.
Somebody put up a link,
put up the link dog,
show me a picture on your phone.
Just don't show it to the camps and just
tweet it.
No one's going to care.
People not sweet.
It's like people on twitter are really
cool.
You can tweet it.
Just a picture,
but don't put her name now.
I can't even do that shit too big
nowadays.
The shit out that bitch.
What's her name?
Hang on.
I almost fucking.
It sounded reasonable to and it came out
of your mouth.
I was like,
yeah,
like oh wait,
no,
that's really good.
Just first and last name.
Really
good at convincing people.
Was the host of fear factor here,
like it's way worse,
which by the way is canceled forever.
No,
it got canceled again for real.
Oh,
sorry.
I'm sorry man.
That's okay.
It's good.
I was 100 percent to horror like.
Yeah.
Thank you very much.
I enjoyed the time.
I enjoyed hanging out with all the fear
factor people.
There is a fucking awesome group of
people,
but I'd rather do my own thing even
though it was great money.
I'm not hurting for money.
I'm all right.
That's the only thing I feel bad for you
for.
It's like,
oh yeah,
it was,
it was fun money.
It was good.
But the reality is I,
I really,
I enjoy working for the ufc and doing
comedy 100 times more.
It was,
it was okay to do.
It was fun.
It was fun to be back with all the
people.
I loved all the people and work with
them again.
But you know,
the difference between the enjoyment
that you get of doing something that
you've really loved doing the enjoyment
was still a bad ass job as far as jobs
go.
It was the fucking shit.
I would never complain about it.
I have in the past and it sounds really
douchey.
That's a problem.
No one can really understand that.
Understand that you get complacent with
it.
Like you start expecting kind of money
once you get it.
It was fun because the people that are
working with were fun.
And the cast of the,
the uh,
the brother,
the contestants this year were awesome.
There was a lot of great contestants,
a lot of really fucking funny people.
Really crazy people,
but it is what it is and it's over the
end.
Apparently it was hard for them to get
advertisers for it.
Oh really?
Damn.
You should have heard that donkey one.
Yeah,
I got it on my phone.
What is that?
Oh,
that's her.
That's her babysitter.
Yeah.
Oh shit.
Let me see
what it also does.
Some sunglasses indoors.
She has a desk.
Yeah.
Oh,
that's her now.
Yeah.
That's not bad.
Where's she live looking thin.
Midwestern.
I say.
Yeah,
it was western.
Did you catch that in the midwest?
That's totally fine.
That's great dude.
She's like a black belt in karate or
something like nice kick your ass and
yeah,
she has a nice family now and yeah,
the kids.
Yeah.
That's my.
No.
Do you have a bit about it?
Yeah,
because I see it friday night at what
time to show shows that 10:00
and go to the ice house comedy dot.
You go.
I'm going to be there on the lineup.
Moshe,
moshe is gonna be their dj deadpan from
tim and eric.
I'm going to try to get on barker
to come down as well because he just
said that he's there friday night until
monday afternoon.
Maybe I'll get him to come around and
we'll do a podcast with him before the
icehouse.
Awesome.
Smart.
Yeah,
and from Australia for till monday.
Said monday.
I'm an icehouse chronicles,
if you will.
We do is the ice house shows are some of
my favorite shows ever.
The standup shows and the podcast shows
we do.
We have a studio in the ice house in
pasadena.
It's a separate room and what we do is
we start the show and we started a
podcast just a little bit before the
show and then people just run back and
do a set and then come back and hang
out.
So fucking best
hamburg.
It's hard.
It's so fun.
The last one I got so fucking high from
that weed.
That's awesome.
I,
I was shaking and then brody was
supposed to be out in front for me.
He's like,
I can't.
Brody said like,
I can't go up and I'm like,
you're king high.
And I'm like,
I've never been to stone before.
And I had to go up,
I was forced to go up and say had the
best that I've ever had in my life.
Oh,
you can go.
Totally worked.
It worked.
Or was it like that time in her life she
had destroyed the support.
She kept saying she got high and wrote
it and she was like,
that sounds awesome.
It was definitely the best.
What's the next morning?
It was a terrible report.
It wasn't joe.
Who is the rich girl.
Not purity.
Blair blair.
Yeah.
It was.
It was kind of hot button.
Three words per page.
She was a little chubby but hot.
She had to fight it.
I'm sure they had network heads.
Listen,
you need to eat less right now.
But she was a good kisser probably.
She kiss you like you ice cream.
Oh god.
I gotta watch that show again with with
them in mind is just young,
young women.
Dirty boarding house.
And how much were they fucking on the
side?
Probably a bunch toward.
For a woman who was in a position like
that where they become like super,
super successful,
it's probably hard for them to find
mates if a woman is making a ton of
money,
like a jennifer aniston type woman.
She's dating something like regular dude
now.
Right?
Isn't she date?
And some like regular guy.
It's hard to get someone to looking at
you as a regular person.
Yeah.
It takes a long time.
Well,
not only that man.
I think for women it's like a normal
thing for the man to be more successful
than the woman.
Yeah.
And when the woman is like way more
successful than the man,
I think it gets sketchy.
Yeah.
You know,
I was in some way to your room at some
of something like tennis or something.
And uh,
I saw a magazine with one hot chick
from,
um,
not the 100 proof from the desperate
housewives,
the one he's been superman,
lois and superman.
Oh,
the fake.
Even not even the glory of the one who
is just slightly less hot that eva
longoria.
Oh,
tara.
Tara hatchet teri hatcher.
Terri hatcher.
Geriatric care was waY hotter.
We ended up getting a taro patch in
where it would be a shit if they just
put her on one of those shows,
but she said from now on,
she's like,
she's not going to look like herself.
Pay for a date.
She still expects everyone to pay
realize.
Yeah,
because that's hoW it works.
What?
No,
that's ridiculous.
She's worth like $100.
What do you mean you have so much more
money than me?
Just pay for it.
Yeah.
No,
I mean you have to pay for it.
You have to buy her dinner and then beg
for sex,
you know,
and then you know,
it's just probably not India anyway,
so probably not.
Yeah.
You would have to be like some brad pitt
to over stimulate a woman like that.
Oh yeah.
You'd have to be like someone's even
more famous than her,
or even more powerful than her.
I mean,
I would think you would say no.
Mean people tell you you fucking
ridiculous.
Your point of view is stupid.
It's asinine.
There is a certain chimpanzee,
logical.
They want someone to do that to them.
They want an alpha.
They want sometimes some people,
even the ones that don't matter,
how long do they last?
Like our friend for instance,
who will remain nameless,
who recently left his girl who also
remain nameless,
and he was in the beta position during
the entire relationship.
I knew.
I'm like,
this shit ain't gonna work.
How the fuck is this going to work?
Women like that alwaYs complained that
the dude does it.
The other ones don't work.
Either those ones will have Better
relationships,
but he was.
The alpha doesn't worK either.
Then was he ever the.
I don't know what he talking about.
How dare you?
I've never seen that.
Turn around.
Make shit up.
Anyway,
go to a go to joe rogan.net.
Check out the information for all the
upcoming shows.
The january or march,
second through fourth in town.
marcia,
are you first weekend?
Powerful art should fear will be with
me,
California.
Oh great.
Yeah,
I'll totally powerful.
Arusha.
Fear.
There you go.
Folks saw that booked on the spot.
That's how we do the aprIl 13th through
15th.
I met the hollywood Florida improv.
Oh shit.
That's the hard rock down there.
Crazy one for 20 atlanta,
Georgia.
That's a tabernacle.
Tickets go on sale tomorrow and then on
May 4th,
New York city.
The what is it?
The fucking manhattan theater mandira.
Sure.
That today I in and I'm in alberta.
Calgary.
Remember the place we did in calgary?
We had to have in the rounds for seats
behind you?
Yeah,
we had a great.
That was awesome.
We need to play Japan while we're there.
There's a comedy store in.
They're in Japan or something like I
want to just go hang out.
If you want to go to the comedy store,
we'll go and isn't there one like a
comedy store in the company in Brazil
was fun just to hang out.
We had a good time already and I had
some real brazilian shoe.
Haas Korea.
Food was so good.
We went back,
we went back to the so good.
So many different flavors to.
To rio is amazing.
That's why I got those coconut water.
I finally,
I was just walking on the beach and just
like they have sold those coconut or
whatever and they just chop it open and
give you a straw.
You know,
they sell that here in los angeles,
so it's fruit stands at any mexican when
the fruit shop coconuts and they just
sent me about that by me.
And your idea is columbus,
Ohio When you're doing that week in May
19th,
yeah.
They asked for me and joey.
That's awesome.
Crazy.
Awesome.
Perfect.
The first time I ever on the road.
Yeah.
19th something like count your tickets.
You know what I'm saying?
Can't get tickets to that guy.
You know,
it was going to make some posters.
I might bring a desk,
one poster who was um,
who was booked this to joey booking
jelly booked that some woman came up to
him and said that she wanted to book me
and joey.
That's awesome.
Beautiful.
At the same club,
the funny bone.
AnD then we're trying to do,
uh,
we're also doing maybe scully's on Ohio
state campus or we might do cleveland.
The funny letters go somewhere else to
cleveland's good to skip over.
Do the improv and cleveland the funny
bone.
And this is an awesome fucking club.
So that's one of the,
one of the great clubs in the country as
far as like how it's low and tight.
That's a great fucking place.
Alright.
So that's all that information.
Higher primate dr.
Fuck yeah.
What do you got?
Well,
in march,
March 15th,
I'm going,
I'm easton,
Maryland.
At the avalon theater.
Do you have a website where everybody
can see all your data?
You don't remember this or the.com?
Boom.
You can remember that.
Or all a r I s h a f f I r on twitter.
I'll be an addison on April 12th through
the 15th at the addison improv.
Let me headline the headline.
That's awesome dude.
Addison texts and this is the shit
addison apparently was the one city,
uh,
in dallas back in the olden days where
you could drink.
Oh,
rose wides,
wild.
It's like really was during prohibition.
They used to have weird laws about the
city of dallas,
but addison was where you can go to
drink and smoke.
Remember,
I think you might still be able to smoke
in the club.
It might be one of the last places that
maybe they changed that.
I hope they didn't.
Even though I hate cigarettes,
I also like personal freedom.
Yeah,
that's the problem.
That's the one where the fringe.
Not other people.
Yeah,
so we're stinky.
Well,
the real issue is for work.
They're stinky,
but it's also.
There's something about girls that smoke
there,
sluttier.
She'll just know that they make
decisions that just don't matter.
Yeah,
they're crazy bitches.
They're throwing cigarettes out the
window and they don't even thinking
about where it goes in to sign.
The chevron addict down their mouth.
The loads go off.
They're not thinking about what's going
in there.
They're not thinking about that sticky
dick.
They just send out a hundred percent of
the time.
It helps your odds.
It increases the odds of finding a way
to actually see a girl with red nail
polish and she's chewing gum and she
spits her gum out into the bushes and
then lights a cigarette.
That girl might suck dick.
I said,
what are we doing later?
That girl might be crazy.
She's not thinking about shit.
She's just living for momentary little
blips of thrills.
If you're interested in coming to the
ice house,
go to,
what is it?
Ice house comedy.com.
And search for joe rogan.
Where?
Death squad?
Yes.
Stage two.
Stage two,
because that's what we're doing.
And matt in march,
we're going to do a fuckload dates there
because I'm going to be around.
Most of them are mr.
Fear factor.
I think you're off the fact.
Forgot about that girl.
That girl in the last monster.
You're going to tell you friends having
something with our friend aside.
A little accent is just so bad and while
they were doing it,
she was going again.
Italia France.
You got to tell you a friend.
Yeah.
He told us this because it was gross.
He told us the opposite.
That liKe he was a stud.
I'm bragging,
I'm pillows.
how sad it was.
Harry is sobering up.
Well,
he's half hard inside of her and she's
going again.
I know I saw a girl walk across That.
That old.
What was it?
Old room,
but they don't have any more connection.
Connection and she was super hot.
Walked all The way across the room,
like outside there was like,
whoosh,
just looking right at me and she just
comes over.
She was one of the bathroom,
but she stopped and came to me.
She goes,
Yeah,
well pesi funny or whatever.
Crap,
go.
Piss off.
Wicked has killed it all.
You just teach her to talk different.
She'd be fine.
Yeah,
you can do that though.
Wouldn't have the patience to do that.
You know,
that girl used to from Texas?
Uh,
jessica,
she,
she would like have the thickest.
When I first met her at the thickest
accent,
it was just like,
all y'all sound like she was a
hillbilly,
that she moved to la,
completely lost it and then move back.
But when she went home to visit it came
back a little stronger.
I would have asked her to keep it.
I love that accident.
Texas oxidants.
My favorite was a real women.
Those are women,
you know what I mean?
They like want to be women.
They don't want to be president and they
want to be running shit.
They like to be in women.
The man,
the areas where the men are manly,
like who's manlier than Texas dudes,
you know,
it's like big belt buckles and fucking
trucks in the.
Mainly those are the women,
the women you know.
Whereas you get to san francisco,
you get chicks and one a fucking stuff,
a birkenstock up your ass scream at you
because you know you don't want to give
them the right to choose.
Obviously these are generalizations,
generalizations.
We're just talking here.
It's impossible for girls in Texas even
roll their eyes really well either.
Just so laid back.
Go to higher primate.com.
If you're interested in monkeys and weed
and psychedelics.
That's my teacher at line.
Brian's reminded me.
He's right and you need sales to sales
or coupons for that.
Okay.
I'll get a coupon stuff that you're not
going to sell much more around for
awhile.
You got to keep on asking me this.
You need to make a coupon code.
You know what bands deal.
This is why my new thing.
I think you should do it as a teacher of
the year every year.
Some new design.
Oh,
that's a good idea.
You know,
because they had the old last year,
his teacher that's 50 percent off.
You know,
we should do.
We should do a jo rogan experience
podcast tee shirt by this dude,
which worldwide sweatpants,
whatever the fuck his name is.
Foremost sweat pants,
sweatpants.
That's not like Mike Maxwell,
but maxwell did a great job with the
chicago posters to have this guy.
Awesome guy do it to a tee shirt,
but like,
that's not a bad idea.
What should it be on it?
The death Squad cat.
Tired of that.
Capra.
especially when you changed.
I'm just going to change them just to
fuck monkey todd over.
I changed it because those guys would
have the tattoo you marketing tool.
That's why I said like,
hey,
I'm going to get a tattoo.
I'm like,
don't do that.
I'm what?
Don't fucking build heroes out of
nowhere.
Well,
it's cool.
It's like you old marvel logo.
It's kind of hipper.
The old cat.
ExactlY.
Yeah.
A marketing.
Oh yeah.
Right.
It's good move.
We started this new drink at the comedy
store.
It's called suck my cock.
No,
it's delicious.
ShIrley's conscious.
Delicious with,
with,
with.
What's it called?
Rum.
Cherry rum.
Oh,
what is it?
Shirley temple with cherry rum in it.
And so at first we called it surely
period,
but then we thought that just wouldn't
catch on enough.
So he called temple of doom way.
Yeah,
exactly.
So now it's just going to be,
hey,
you know what they originally called
this.
Oh,
this will be part of the folklore.
And so that's a drink that they sell the
store now you.
Yeah.
Oh that's cool.
So you only the front bar would know
about it and I guess the backbar.
Well if you order it though,
someone could ask some of the more there
if you're working.
Yeah.
And they get order.
Probably anytime the front bars up on.
they'll know now everybody knows now.
Do you get like a copyright on that
already?
Just some satisfaction of knowing you
have something to do with it.
That'd be bad aSs.
We were in vegas a couple of years from
now.
We were at temple of doom and everybody
knew what it was.
It's so delicious.
right before you had sex,
you could have any super alcoholic.
You can't taste it.
Podcasts over brian,
how dare you?
Uh,
so we'll,
we'll try to get arch bargain for
tomorrow.
No guaranteeS though,
but for sure we were doing this house
chronicles,
you think they might send me to
Australia to what?
For september to do like a run of the
city's.
Oh,
one night.
In each city.
They might send you who?
The agent got married there.
I don't know if you've talked a list
type talk.
Talking bill.
Oh,
that's cool.
Isn't that the people that we worked
with were there,
is it?
Yeah,
I'm pretty sure.
they cool.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
they were great.
Yeah,
Australia is awesome man.
It's just too far away.
I'm a,
I would go for like two weeks for those
asking about the ufc in Australia.
I'm not going,
I'm not going to any of the fx or fuel
shows that there are four channels I'm
doing.
I'm doing only the oneS that are on
paper view and the fox ones,
those are the ones I'm doing it.
So I got to watch last night,
jake ellenberger and diego sanchez went
to a war.
Holy shit.
That was a great fight.
Classic fight of the year,
Canada.
They should do one of those tests now
that you're not going to.
Totally shoot.
We should've done it tonight.
Next time.
We'll do that.
We'll do a drunk caSt plan.
Yeah,
we'll,
we'll do it.
We'll broadcast.
Uh,
I've never done it.
I'll bring it.
I'll put,
you know what?
I'll set up a second tv in here.
I'll bring a tv in here.
We just do at the ice house or we do.
You don't have a tv.
The ice house and we're not going to do
it illegal.
You know,
we don't have to do illegal right now.
Next box.
Oh,
you read it on an xbox?
Yeah.
Really?
Or just get me an xbox code from dana.
I'm sure he had someone who can get you
and hey,
we got this code.
I'd rather pay for it.
Like,
oh god damn.
Good citizen.
what are you saying?
50 bucks.
We have nothing.
I'll tell you.
Like,
oh,
probably if it's the private stuff.
Oh the guys who sent us the super cool
bond.
If you're a,
if you're interested in it,
go to jet water pipes dot coM.
That's the name of it.
It's pretty bad ass.
A good.
My full support.
Me to brian for stars us.
I'll be in toronto,
March 23rd.
I think.
ari,
the great.com.
Go to either great taco or the
great.com.
That's how you go.
Ari shaffir on twitter,
a r I,
s h a f f I r hollow.
This one.
This is a gooD one.
Yeah,
I enjoyed.
Bond was really good.
It really.
I'm focused on.
Um,
what,
what can we tell you that hasn't already
been said?
Folks,
we love you.
We appreciate you.
Most of you.
There's a few of these that are pretty
fucked up and you need to go.
Go to kill yourself.
Kill yourself.
You know,
just get a fleshlight site.
Gets higher,
some iowasca and your system,
you know,
you'll feel Bad.
Go,
uh,
go to Costa Rica.
have an ibogaine session.
Oh,
aubrey.
Formerly known as chris,
the artist formerly known as chris is
going there soon.
He's going to do ibogaine in Costa Rica
and he's going to come back and tell us
everything.
So it's gonna.
Come back with a different name.
Now henry is going to be crystal.
Fuck no flour,
no flour child.
Oh,
and I have a podcast skeptic,
a skeptic.
Thank you already for years.
Should be the arch of your show changed?
For sure.
We have just the ra ra,
ra,
and that's by the way.
That's pretentious enough and it's only
because I'm a huge jimmy hendrix fan.
I basically ganged it.
That's it.
This fucking shoWs over.
Thanks to the flashlight for sponsoring
our program.
If you go to joe rogan.net,
click on the link for the fleshlight
entering rhogam or you want one?
I got a box of them.
We have a stack and we got you a new
girlfriend dog answering the codename
rogan.
You get 15 percent off.
We're also sponsored by onnit.com.
It's o n n I t,
and if you go to joe rogan.net
and see the link for alpha brain,
the cognitive enhancing supplement that
I took to be so smooth.
You've got some coolers.
Card?
Yeah.
I started puttiNg up some cool shit.
Yeah,
I got a bunch of shit.
I put up this.
Those are all,
uh,
what the fuck's his name?
Ralph steadman.
Those are stebbins.
So the cool.
I've heard of him,
right?
Yeah.
He's the guy that did all of 100
thompson's artwork.
It was a pretty bad.
Yeah.
I decided to dress this place up and oh,
I should say the name of this fucking
guy because I keep forgetting.
Hold on a second.
Go to guy who did the thing behind
brian.
I know as I was going to ask you about
that.
My website's desk wIde.tv.
I have reviewed a veto right now also.
We have.
What'd you think of god cast?
I just put up,
I got new brian cowen,
which has.
How podcast do you have?
Five million thousand.
Oh,
if you want to watch the best podcast
that we do,
it's the ice house kronites as far as
fun and that's also available on on the
desk squad label along.
I don't think they'll hold the really
long though.
Like a lot of them are four hours and
shit.
Go to refresh.
Go to joe rogan.
Done it now.
What's your squad?
That tv.
Go to itunes.
Subscribe to desk.
One last 24 hours to vote for me for
that web short.
He shows I'm not supporting you on.
This is ridiculous.
A grant grand is the name of this dude
who made this awesome fucking collage
grant grant grant grant.
It's.
I'm fucking just all kinds of cool
designs and all sorts of weird shit that
he incorporated in their.
Amazing.
It's really cool.
So a grant.
Thank you very much.
Thank you for your table and we're
starting to pocket sports podcast.
Sounds awful.
Sports you into ufc basketball was like
the worst idea ever.
I'm flashlight.
Done on it.
On.com.
Done.
Entering the code name.
Rogan.
It's 10 percent off from now on every
order.
It's not just your first order at
[inaudible] dot com.
It's every order.
Okay.
You need more scIence minded.
Double blind placebo studies on the way.
Okay.
We're working on it,
but you want everything we're supposed
to do.
Hey man.
Did you know that steve novella
criticize your scientific report?
Yep.
We corrected everything and he critiqued
and we actually hired a scientific
advisor.
We're doing all the right things for
you.
Yes,
we're doing all the right things.
We're trying to keep it together.
It's all for the positive.
It's for you.
This whole things for you.
It's for me because we are all one,
and as we grow,
you grow with us.
You are not the you,
the he used to be.
You are the accumulation of all your
life's experiences and from now on,
be the best person you possibly can.
Be the funniest,
the coolest,
heavy shit together.
Be the hero in your own story.
There should be an after the marines
should.
It should be a fucking recruit an agent.
I'm gonna.
Start my own marines.
Someday.
We're going to get our cult.
We're going to.
We're going to start one.
We're definitely going to start a
compound.
You want to build the house I'm thinking
of for no bullshit.
I'm thinking of buying a giant chunk of
land.
Meadow lake,
and we all build houses.
They're Just build a like amish people.
Yeah.
Well listen man,
the land,
I will buy the land so we'll own the
land and then allow all my friends to
come and build up houses.
Let's just have some bad ass houses on
this piece of public.
Does that tell you a good idea?
And if we hear the incoming sooner like
a,
you want to go over there and do it,
I wouldn't be willing to do fear factor
for one more season just for the money
for that.
I think it's a good idea.
You're willing to for a factor anyway,
for one more time.
I would've kept going.
That's why I'm glad I had that terrible
bargaining.
This fucking podcast is over support ari
shaffir by going to all read the
great.com
and by subscribing to his podcast,
which is ari shaffir skeptic tank,
which is only available on I tunes and
already the great.com
and stItcher,
stitcher,
and do you have the right mp3 available
on your website?
So if someone has a fuckin zune or
something,
they can download link for it.
Yeah.
You don't have to be like.
It doesn't happen.
You don't have to go to itunes or any of
those.
Beautiful.
Come on folks that can't get any nicer
and smoother and easier.
When are you going to do a fucking
visual version of it?
Like this for you?
Stream.
We're doing that for the sports
podcasts.
We're not going to do it for.
That's going to be called punchdrunk.
Okay.
Did you have a really good one?
Recently when you interviewed a hooker?
Interviewed hooker was really good and a
lot of good stuff about the holocaust.
Survivors was really good.
Who?
What is the uh,
what,
what episode is the hooker?
40.
40 folks.
Tomorrow night we'll see you at the ice
house in pasadena.
What time to show time brian?
Ten o'clock show podcast starts at nine
at you stream tv there.
I'm pretty sure.
Come.
He's hilarious.
Yeah,
I would love to have him come.
All right.
Let's fucking shows over tonight.
Will love you.